hi everyone welcome to this php and
mysql full course by simply loan
with businesses becoming online there is
a need for companies to build
interactive websites to catch the
attention of customers and construct
their brand
it has become really important for any
business to have its presence online and
for that a website is most crucial
when your audience visits your website
it delivers them their first impression
of your business
having a really creative website
increases brand awareness saves money on
advertising and helps build trust with
your audience
instead of paying for expensive offline
and online ads you can invest in seo
promotion of your own page which brings
enduring results
a website also helps to address customer
issues better
it also sets the impression for customer
service
now php and mysql are two popular
technologies used in website development
php is a server-side general purpose
scripting language that is specifically
used for web development
while mysql is an open source relational
database management system that helps to
automate data retrieving and provides
great support in php mysql web
application development
so mysql is greatly scalable and is the
first choice for psp developers
now with this understanding let's look
at the agenda for today's topic
on php and mysql full course
so first we will start with
understanding
php programming concepts and then look
at object oriented programming in php
after that we will learn about using php
with mysql and
understand some of the grid operations
and create a login form using php
moving forward we will develop a web
application using php
next we will understand the basics of
mysql and
relational database management system
next
we look at some of the basic mysql
commands such as select
update delete and others
then you will get an idea about using
joins in mysql
and
after that
you will learn an advanced topic that is
stored procedures in mysql finally we
will end our full course video by
understanding
the different php and mysql interview
questions that are frequently asked
let us first meet rob
rob is the owner of an e-commerce
business
earlier his customers were very happy
with the products they purchased from
his website
but with more traffic and user base rob
started receiving complaints from his
customers
not related to the products but the
website itself
now the customers were facing challenges
like slow website speed bad user
experience and poor security features
like any other business owner rob wanted
to rectify the problem but he was unable
to find a solution to it
well developing his websites in php can
solve all of rob's problem and guess
what php is simple to learn and easier
to implement
let me elaborate on this the php is
useful in many ways as
first and foremost it can make the
website function faster
it can create dynamic web pages and
dynamic web pages are what makes a
website more interactive
next it provides security encryption
it is a cost efficient language
it is very compatible as it works
efficiently with different databases and
programming languages
and it is platform independent which
means a php application can run on any
environment
now before moving into the details did
you know that
79.2 percent web is still powered by php
which nearly translates to 20 million
websites and 1 million web servers
now in this presentation
you'll learn about what is php
how does it work differently from a
conventional web page
what are its features
some major companies where php is
implemented
prerequisites on learning it
and finally we will have a look at the
demo for our first php program
now without further ado
let's get started
so what exactly is php php stands for
hypertext preprocessor which is a
recursive acronym
it is an open source server-side
scripting language that is embedded into
html and used for web development
now before we get overwhelmed by the
technical terms let me simplify them for
you
now for those of you who don't know open
source is a term for technology which
means it is freely available to everyone
while server-side scripting means that
from writing the code to implementing
and processing it everything is done on
the server side while the user just lays
down and enjoys the experience
now that we know what php is
let's see how a php script looks like
as you can see on the screen this is the
syntax of php
it opens with an angle bracket question
mark php and ends with a question mark
and an angle bracket
while the code comes in between them
now as you can notice
this is very similar to how html codes
are written
now let's have a look at some features
of php
now while php being a very diverse and
feature rich language some of its main
features are listed here
let us try and understand them one by
one first is simple
now this feature comes as a good news to
new learners since php is simple and
hence an easy to learn language
next comes flexibility
php is a highly flexible language in
conventional web pages even the smallest
of changes have to go through the
developer who changes the code to
implement them
well php gives you the flexibility to
make small changes without the
intervention of the developer itself
it is also platform independent which
means it does not require any special
plugins to run and can basically run on
any environment
next is interpreted php is an
interpreted language and does not
compile the entire code hence taking
less time
which takes us to our next feature that
is fast
websites developed in php are faster
this is why developing dynamic websites
using php is considered as the best
option
as discussed earlier too php is called
as an open source language which means
it is free to use and implement
next feature is security
the language consists of a few built-in
frameworks that provides benefits like
encryption and hence protection from
cyber attacks
next is a large php community since php
is an old language it has grown up to a
large community which is very helpful
and makes the language more stable
so that was all about features of php
moving forward let us discuss the
workflow of a php web page
how does a ph page work
so for a better understanding let us
first see how a basic html page
functions
in the basic html workflow when you open
a website on your browser
a request is sent from the browser to
the server and the server then returns
the requested page stored on it back to
the browser
now that's it no matter what device or
what purpose you open the website for
the page return is always the same or
you can say static now what php does
different is when you open a website
developed in php
a request in dot php extension is sent
to the server
into the server there exists a php
interpreter which recognizes the dot php
file and interprets it based on the
request from the browser
it pulls out data from its database and
file systems and returns a html page
personalized according to the user
now let me give you an example to make
it more clear when you log into your
account on drops new ecommerce website
made on php it takes your unique request
to the server and shows you products
based on your past preference and liking
instead of showing you the exact same
page every time
now this makes the website dynamic and
more interactive to the user
also guys before moving forward if you
are enjoying this video please give a
thumbs up and subscribe to simply learn
for more such content
so that was all about the workflow of
php
let us discuss the companies using them
many companies have reached great
success by implementing php into their
websites
let me list down a few of them
first comes facebook the biggest social
media platform
did you know that facebook was created
entirely on php
and according to the website similar web
php is visited by users for nearly 22
billion times per month this means the
social media platform has to deal with
huge traffic volumes and php helps a
website with this
now before moving to the next website a
quick question for you guys
what is the one site everyone goes to
for information
correct it's wikipedia
and guess what it is written in php2
now platforms like wordpress which are
used to create beautiful websites itself
are also based on php
and blogging and social media channels
such as tumblr and even
multi-service platforms like yahoo which
face huge amounts of data traffic every
day uses php to function
so now that i hope you're more motivated
to learn php
let us look at some of the prerequisites
of learning it
now since php scripts as already
discussed are embedded into html codes a
basic understanding of html comes
naturally as a prerequisite
again a website cannot be complete
without the implementation of css hence
a basic understanding of css is also a
must
next is basic knowledge of programming
language now this is not necessarily a
prerequisite but if you have basic
knowledge of programming fundamentals
such as oops concept
functions and errors etc it would really
help you along the way
let's get started and learn what exactly
is zam
now zam stands for cross platform
apache server maria database php
and then finally perl
xampp is an open source application that
is developed by apache friends and is
one of the easiest ways to host a local
web server with access to mysql database
php and perl
so it is an all-in-one package
so now that we have an understanding of
what zamp is let us set up the software
on our system and then see how to use it
to run a php script
so now to set up the xampp software what
we need to do is
let us open the browser
and
download
our software
so as you can see here
apachefriends.org is the official
website from where you can download the
sam software
since we are using the windows version
we'll download it for windows
although it is available for linux and
mac os as well
now let's wait for the download to get
finished
it almost is
now let's open the setup and install our
software right away
continue installation
next
now from here you can select all the
extra files that you want to install
along with the xampp setup or you don't
want to install
now this is the default folder for zamp
installation that is c drive sam and i
would recommend you keep it that way
i think there's some issue here
yeah well
this is the
folder for my old amp
now
we wait for the installation to get
finished and then we'll run a quick php
script a welcome or hello world kind of
script to see how this zam software
functions along with php
now the installation is almost done
we'll just wait for a few
now the installation is complete and
now let us open the control panel to
check if it's
done correctly
yes
everything seems fine now so this is the
control panel for the xampp software
which includes all the services provided
by it and in our php tutorials we'll be
mainly using the apache server and the
mysql one so you need to click on apache
server
started and mysql
now apache server will show you the
default port on which it is running now
to check if xampp is correctly installed
on your system let's open the browser
again
and type
localhost
now this will open up the dashboard for
the xampp application
let's click on phpmyadmin
and
the information is available here so
the installation is complete
similarly we'll install the visual
studio code since i've already installed
the software on my system i'll not be
doing that now
let us come to the important part
let us redirect to c drive
and there we have a xampp installed
open the xampp folder and locate htdocs
now this is the folder where all your
php files codes and website related data
will be stored
now we'll open the htdocs and let us
create a new folder here
since it will be a first program let us
name it
first
php
now let's open our code editor that is
visual studio code
click on open folder
locate to
xampp
htdocs
and the folder we created first php
as you can see let me close this first
as you can see first php folder is
visible here
let us create our first php file
let's name it
hello dot php now don't forget the dot
php extension otherwise the code will
not run now since a browser only
understands html code we will have to
embed the php script into the html code
itself so let's begin
let me zoom it a little bit so you can
see clearly
let me
add a heading so h1 will be too big
let's keep it to h2
my
first
php
webpage
let's write our first php script so a
php script begins with an opening
angular bracket
question mark
php
now
we'll write the php script that is echo
hello world now echo acts as a print
function which prints any string that is
in front of it in this case it will
display hello world onto the webpage
let's close the script with a question
mark and a closing angular bracket
and also close our html code
now before running a web page let us
first check if the web server is still
active
yes the web server is still running
so let's open the browser type localhost
now type the name of the
folder that you've created that is
first
php
now as you can see our hello.php file is
presented let's click on it
and as you can see our first web page is
visible
which shows the heading my first php
webpage and the hello world from a php
script
in this video on php programming we're
going to discuss different php concepts
from the very basics such as syntax
hello world program up until learning
how to collect form data using php
scripts and also cover a lot more
concepts in between now what we need to
do is to use visual studio code
what we do is we go to c drive
xampp folder or wherever you have
installed your xampp server
we go to that folder
locate htdocs
and let us now create another folder and
you can name it
anything that you want to based on your
project
since we are discussing the concepts let
us
name it concepts
now right click on it and
here as you can see it shows open with
code
when you click on it
you can see that it opens visual studio
code for you
along with the concepts folder that we
just created now this is where you will
create all your files for your project
and will be writing all your all of your
php scripts
now let's create the first php file from
here
new file
let us name it tutorial
dot php
and
see how a php syntax looks like
so a php syntax begins with an angular
opening bracket question mark
php
and ends with a question mark and a
closing angular bracket
while
the php
script
goes
in between
so this is the very basic syntax of how
php scripts are written
now let us move on and see
how to write a hello world program using
a php script
so
to print something on php
echo is used
now to use echo what you need to do is
just write the string that you want to
print in front of it
and save the program
so
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
let us close it
and
save the file
now i am going to show you how to use
the sam software in order to run php
scripts
go
and open your xampp control panel
and from the control panel you have to
start this first service that is apache
now this is going to start a local web
server on your system
now open your browser
go to a new tab and type localhost
followed by the name of the folder that
we just created into htdocs that was
concepts
and hit enter
here you can see the file that we just
created tutorial.php
and when you click on it
you can see your first program visible
here hello and welcome to simply learn
now suppose you have a program that
needs to print this exact same string
again and again throughout the program
so
what are you going to do
type the entire echo statement
through your code
or make it simpler
now to make it simpler what we need to
do is we need to go back to our code
and discuss the concept of
variables
now to create a variable
what we need to do is we need to
use this dollar sign
followed by the name of the variable you
can name it anything you want so let us
name it str
and type
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
so
this is a first variable now this
variable str stores this string value
also you can create different variables
for different purposes such as if you
want to store a number suppose
so
you can store number five
and
suppose you want to store a floating
variable
and that would be float
and a floating variable is a number of
decimal points so 7.6
so now we have three variables in a
program
now one thing to notice if you're coming
from a different programming language is
that you don't need to define the type
of variable in php that is if it is a
string number or a floating variable
now to print this
we can use echo but when you want to
print a variable in echo you need to do
things a little differently so
let us start with h1 heading
now to print a variable what you need to
do is you need to use
dot
followed by the name of the variable
that would be
str
and another dot
followed by if you want to type
something
along with the variable
i'm going to copy this code
and paste it
now
let us change the size of the headings
and also change a variable so in the
second line we are going to print num
and in the third
the float that we created
so now we have all of our
variables into our echo
now let us save this program and see
what it does
so as you can see
the variables are printed on your
program and you don't have to write them
again and again you can simply write
name of the variable along with echo and
dot
and print it along
now that we know about variables suppose
you want to print the names for
different laptop brands available in the
market
now what you're going to do
do you create different variables for
each name that is available for hp a
variable for lenovo variable for a
source
or do you want a single variable to
store store all of the names of the
laptop brands available
now with errors it is possible to store
different information
of the same data type that is integer
string
under a
single
variable
the condition is all of the
data that is stored under the variable
should have the same data type
now
let us see how array works
now
array
stores multiple values in a single
variable as we already discussed
now to make an array
first what we need to do is
name a variable
laptop
brand
and
type in
array function
and under that function
we are going to write the names of
different laptop brands that is hp
with separated by commas
lenovo
asus
and
dell
so
suppose these are the four laptop brands
that are available in the market in your
area
now
what you need to do is you need to print
what is
in this
particular variable that is laptop brand
so
to print it
you need to first create
variable dump now what variable dump
does is it as you can see here
it
exports the variable that is in its
function
now
we are going to
write the variable that we just created
into the variable dump function and it
will just return the data type and value
now suppose you want to print it
so to print it what we need to do is
just add echo in front of it
okay now before moving on to seeing the
result of this program
let us just
make this part of the code
inactive
now to do that
we are going to learn a new concept in
between that is comments
so comments are the lines in a code that
are not
executed while
the program is run
so
a single line comment starts with two
slash
and anything written in front of it is
does not run along with the code
so
these comments are very useful when
you're writing a
code
to make your code readable and more
understandable by any coder who will
or might later on using the code that
you just created now suppose what we can
do with
comments is
i'm going to write a comment just in
front of it
this
is a
string
variable
now
after these
slashes
anything written is not executed when i
am going to run the program
also now
what do you do if you want to
make this whole part of the code not
functioning
do you add
two slashes in front of everything
or you can use a much simpler method
that is multi multi-line comments to use
multi-line comments what you're going to
do is
your slash
star
this marks the start of the multiline
code and
to end this use star and slash again
and everything in bit bean does not run
when you're going to run your program
so
we will now see
how this
array works
we will just
reload this page and as you can see
hp lenovo asus and dell are visible here
also you might notice
this array 4 shows the length of the
array
and this shows
the position where all of these
strings are inside the array that is an
array starts with the zero position not
one but zero so the first would be zero
position that is hp
and then one lenovo and subsequently
asus and then
suppose you just want to print the
second variable in your array what you
need to do is you need to go back to
your code
and
in front of the variable you need to
write the position that you want to
print
under square brackets that is the second
position
in array would be number one
and save the code
go back to the
browser and only the second
array is the second
variable in the array is visible
now suppose instead of a variable you
want to create a value
that you don't want to be changed
throughout your entire program
so
consonants are used for the same purpose
now consonants are very much like
variables except that once they are
defined they cannot be changed or
undefined
so
let us see how consonants work
first
we will
put this code
under a comment
and
now start writing a consonant
so to define or create a consonant what
you need to do is
use the
define function
and inside the define function what you
need to do is
you need to
write the name of the
consonant
and
okay first let us write the name of the
consonant
suppose
laptops
followed by
the value
of the
hp
consonant
lenovo
and
asus
and that's it and you close the define
function and there you have defined your
consonant in your php script now this
cannot be changed or undefined
throughout your program
now to print it what you need to do is
type echo followed by the name of the
consonant that you just created so the
name of the consonant is laptops
save the code
go back
and hp lenovo and asus
are visible here
you can also create consonant errors
along with a normal consonant now to
create a consonant array
you just need to add a square bracket
just a second
let me close this one
separated by
commas
and now we have
the names of the laptop as an array
which
by the way cannot be changed or
undefined through your throughout your
code just like any other consonant
now suppose you want to just print the
name of the third laptop that is
available in the market
now what you need to do is you need to
write the position and the third
position in case of arrays would be
number two
save
and only asus is visible here
so this is how consonants and variables
work in php
now before moving on to the next section
let me give you another situation
now suppose i want you to print
a number only and only if it is greater
than 7
how do you do that
now since it is a condition conditional
statements are used to perform different
actions based on different conditions
now some of the conditional statements
include in php are if
if else
if else if else and switch and we're
going to discuss them one by one
no so the first one is if
now
let me create a variable let us name it
there
and
write the value 8.
now
the example that we just discussed
if we want to check
if
this variable is greater than 7 and only
and only then
print the variable on a screen
now to do that what we need to do is
type in if
and in the bracket we need to type the
condition that we're going to check that
is if
variable
greater than
7
now use curly brackets
and inside the curly bracket
write the code that you want to execute
only and only if the condition in of
this
if is met
so we need to print this variable so
echo
where
and go and save it now go back
and reload and you can see it is printed
here
now let us go back and change the value
of the variable to 5
and save it
go back reload
and as you can see nothing is printed on
the screen since the condition that we
just mentioned inside if does not meet
now suppose
i tell you that
if the condition does not meet you have
to
print
a string
saying that the condition does not did
not meet
how do you do that
to do it what you need to add after if
is
else
and else does not need to have a
condition since as the english
word suggests it is else
which means the condition of if did not
meet
and inside the else we are going to
write the code
echo the
condition
did
not meet
save it
the condition did not meet
now time for another condition
now suppose i want i ask you to check if
a number is divisible by 2
3 or both
how do you do that
now to do that
first
let us
create a number
6.
now check if
variable
percent
2
is equals equals to 0 now what this
shows is this
brings out the remainder and if the
remainder is 0 that means it is
divisible by 2.
and we need to add one more condition
here
and and
variable
percent 3
equals to equals to zero
and
what this does is it checks if both of
these conditions are true that is
if the number
inside the variable is divisible by both
2 and 3
we will display
divisible
by
both
now
what we need to do is we need to
check
if it is divisible by 2.
so
else
if
since it is else if we need to add a
condition in it too else if
variable
percent
2
equals equals to
0.
echo
there is a
built
by
two
similarly
divisible by
three
another you can add as many else if
statements as you want
and the final else will show
okay
let us go back and save our program
since a variable is 6
it should show divisible by both
and you can see it shows exactly the
same divisible by both
now let us change the value and see if
our program works
so what we are going to do is we are
going to change the value to 4
save a program
and run it again
this by 2
similarly
9
divided by 3
and finally
13
not divided by either two or three
so this is how you can make use of if
else if and else statements
now the next conditional statement is
switch statement
now the switch statement is used to
perform different actions based on
different conditions
so let me again give you a situation so
that you understand better
so suppose
you're playing a game
which has four different levels and
first level is easy medium hard and
extreme
so
you need to print that
now what will you do you can also use if
elsa but it's a lot of code
switch statement makes it a lot simpler
and more readable
so
what we need to do is we need to
type in switch
okay first what we need to do is first
we need to create a variable
so a variable
suppose
let us name it level
and
level is three
to create a switch statement you need to
type in switch and
enter the name of the variable that will
be passed into the switch statement to
check for the conditions
level
and it also begins with a curly bracket
and inside
the search statement what you need to do
is you need to type
case
that is
the first case would be case
1
followed by
a colon
and the statement that you want to
execute that is
echo
you
are
playing
at
easy
level
and
since you want
your program to stop here itself what
you need to do is
you need to type in
break
similarly for rest of the levels i'll
just copy this code here
two three and four
and just make the changes
and
similar to if else statements you also
need to add
another statement that would be
default
if any of the conditions are not met in
the switch statement suppose the value
of your variable is 20 which does not
make any sense to the game
then
what you need to do is
you need to
display
a default error message and that would
be
invalid
input
and you also need to
end the switch statement
with
a curly braces
and end the
php program
all right
let us save it
go to a browser
and run you are playing at hard level
i guess you must have understood the
concept let us just one more time
change the value of the variable to 20
save it
go back
invalid input
so this is how the conditional
statements in php work
next what we're going to talk about is
php loops
now suppose you want to run a block of
code or a part of code again and again
and again or in other words in loop
so php has that functionality known as
php loops
to do the same task
now there are different types of php
loops available that is while do while
and for loops which we will be
discussing
in this part of the video
now let us start with the while loop now
the while loop
loops through a block of code as long as
the condition that you have entered or
specified in the while loop is true
so
let me just
remove it
now to write a while loop what you need
to do is
type while
followed by
the condition
and to write the condition what we need
to first do is let us create a variable
and
we'll
give it a value of 2.
now the condition
which we are going to write is this is
just an example
so
if
or while
the value of variable
is
less than equals to
10
and then we follow along with the curly
braces
and type the code that we want to run
again and again until the value of a
variable becomes 10
or
till the value of a variable is less
than 10.
suppose
number
within the variable that is
where
and that's about it
now what we need to do is we need to
increase the value of the variable else
this code this code will run
for an infinite amount of time and the
system might crash
so
to increase the variable in each
iteration what we need to do is we need
to use the plus plus operator
which will increase the value
of the variable by one in each iteration
now we are going to save the code
and run it number 2 3 4 5 6 7
and so on
let me just
add
break here and you can see all of the
numbers up until 10 are visible here
and after 10 the loop just stops
so let me
explain it again so
what we are doing is we are writing
while
along with the condition until
then the code is supposed to be run
again and again
so the condition is if the value of the
variable
is less than or equals to 10 since a
value of
value of our variable is 2 the condition
is true so the code inside of this vial
is executed and the code will display
the value of the number
and the
variable
value will increase with each iteration
until it becomes greater than 10 and
then
the loop will exit
now the do while loop is very very
similar to the while one the only
difference being
in case of a do while loop
a
code
this this code will execute at least
once
i'll show you how it works
so
in case of do while
we start with two
curly braces
let us use this same
example
and after the curly braces what we do is
we
write
while along with the condition
that is
equals to 10.
let me just
okay
now let me tell you what do we need low
value suppose
the value of a variable
is
11 now since the condition
this does not meet
in case of the while loop it will not
even run once now suppose you want to
display the current value of the
variables whether or not if it meets a
condition at least once
so
in case of do while
it will first go into this do loop
run the code and then after the do loop
is complete this part of the code is
complete it will go on to the while part
and check the condition
now if the condition does not meet the
loop will end here and if it meets it
will continue until the condition does
not meet the while part
so it will run at least once
now
save this
and go back to a browser
and reload this program and as you can
see number 11
is visible here
so
do while is helpful in some cases which
you'll realize as long as
you start coding more and more
now next up is follow now for loop is
used when
we already know how many times you want
the loop to run so for loop is used when
you want to run a piece of code a
specific number of times
now let me show you how it works
now the for loop is written in three
parts here we don't need to define a
variable beforehand
the first part of the for loop is
defining the value of the variable so
variable
is equals to let us
valued at one
now we want to make it
run till suppose six values
so what we need to do is
we need to
write the condition
in the second part of the for loop
a variable less than equals to 6
and in the third part will be the
incremental part so as you can notice in
while and do while we put the
incremental part inside the block of the
code here the incremental part is inside
the for function itself
variable plus plus
and then we start with the curly braces
and we write the
code similar to
i'll just
copy it from here
and now let us
just save it and print to show you
how it works
number one two three four five and six
now these loops are a very important
aspect of programming and you all should
try out different problems based on
loops by yourself
now next up in php is php functions
now functions are very very useful and
very important part of programming in
any language
functions are of two types
built-in functions and user-defined
functions
now built-in functions are the functions
that are already present inside the
framework of your programming language
a very popular example
of a function built-in function of php
is echo echo is a function that is
already built in php and is used to
print out
variables strings and values
on the screen
now user defined functions are functions
you create yourself
to use a code
repeatedly in your program
so i'll explain you with while writing
the code itself
so suppose you want to use this for code
four or five times in your program
so
or even more maybe 10 20 30 40 100 times
in your program if you're writing a very
very large program you want to
print or use this part of the code 100
times in your program what do you do do
you write this entire code or copy paste
this entire code again and again 100
times and make your code
lengthier or do you just want to use
this piece of code
from here
from anywhere new program
now to do that we need to
put this piece of code inside a user
defined function
so how do we do that
we do that by
writing
function
followed by
suppose you want to call
this function
a name
name
and start with curly braces
now this is a user defined function
named name
now inside this name function
is a piece of code
this
for
now how do we reuse it
i'll show you in a second
so
suppose you are
a long way from your code from this code
you don't even know where it is you want
to use
this code again after writing hundreds
of lines of code so how do you do it
you just type the name of the function
that is named
and close it that's about it this is
called calling a function so it is
similar to calling a friend for help so
here you just called your friend name
to execute this part of the code
here
save
and
where there are no changes since the
output will be the same
let us make some changes
add another echo
i am
going to
run it
again
later
and
call this function again
save it
and as you can see
once the function is called the output
is printed and i'm going to run it again
later and then again the function is
called and it
uses the same piece of code again and
again and again
see how simple coding can be
when you know what to use when
now let's move ahead and understand the
concepts of oops in php
so as you can see on the screen i have
listed down the eight concepts of oops
that we will be discussing today
first is class
next comes objects then its member
function and member variables then
constructor and destructor
inheritance and finally it is
polymorphism
now let's walk through each of the
concepts one by one
first is class
it is a blueprint of an object that
provides initial values for the state
a class consists of both data and
functions and data and functions
together are called objects
now let's first have a look at the class
let me create a file
named class.php
and let us write the code first
okay
here we are
okay
here i have defined a class by using the
class keyword
followed by fruit which is the class
name
next i have added a pair of curly braces
and added the entire properties and
methods within the braces so as you can
see on the screen we have declared a
class named fruit
that contains two properties called name
and color
along with that i have also added two
methods
set name
and get name
now now the purpose of these methods is
for setting and getting
the name property
so let me give you some in important
information so when you define a class a
variable in it is called property while
a function is known as
method now let us execute the code and
see the output
let's go to the browser
and type localhost followed by the file
name
here's a file class.php
and as you can see on the screen
the code is running perfectly
now that was about the class
next comes objects
so it is an instance of a class
basically
a variable holds a date of a class
now we define a class once
and create as many objects in it
so for a better understanding let me
give you an example
suppose a car is a class so
mercedes-benz and bmw would be objects
now let's see objects
classes are incomplete without objects
so we can add as many objects as we want
from a class
and every single object has the
properties and methods defined in the
class but those objects will have
different property values so objects of
a class are created using the new
keyword
now let me open the code editor
and let's create another file
called
obj dot
so this code will be the same
let's copy
and paste it here
now let me type the code for object
[Music]
as you can see i have used the new
keyword to create object of the class
fruit
similarly
banana would be another object
and now we'll use the set name function
to set
the name to apple
on this object on the apple object that
we have created
similarly we will
set the name
for the banana object
there's an extra bracket here let's move
it
now moving forward let us type the code
to display
what we have added into the objects
for this can you guess which method
we'll be using
yes the get name method
will be used to display
the name saved onto the object using the
set name method
now that our code is complete
let us run and check
if it's working correctly
let me go back
and refresh
now here we have our object.php file
yes the code runs perfectly the fruit
program
and it is displaying apple and banana
from the two objects that we created
i hope now you have clearly understood
the concept moving on to the next one
let's talk about the member variable and
member function
a member variable is defined within a
class
the data can be accessed by the member
functions alone
now once the object is built these
variables are called attributes of the
object
whereas member function is defined
within a class and is used to access
object data so next comes constructor
so it allows an individual to alert an
object's properties
while the object creation
while a destructor is a function that is
called when the object stops working
we will have a look at the constructor
program
so constructor allows an individual to
alert an object's properties while the
object creation
now suppose you build a program using
constructor function
php will automatically call the
construct function while creating an
object from a class also remember that
when you write the construct function
always prefix it with two underscores
now let's have a look at the example
where we will be using a constructor
function with calling the set name
method
now this set name function is often used
when you assign a value to the name
attribute
now let's open the code editor and
create a constructor file
[Music]
will again create the two properties
named
name
and color
now we will create a constructor
with two underscores
and a construct keyword
and i'll give the two properties as
attributes to the constructor
now in this
program we will be using the constructor
function
as the set
method
to set the names
and color of a fruit by default
during the object creation itself
we still need to create the get
functions
now let's create an object to invoke the
constructor
now since the constructor has attributes
we will have to give the values for the
attributes as well
so the fruit would be
strawberry
and
color
would be pink
so this creates a new object and it
gives
the values to the constructor
okay
in the php script
and
our html code as well
let us save the code and check if it's
working
let's go back
refresh
now constructor file is visible let's
click on it and yes so
when the object strawberry is created
the attributes we have given to the
constructor strawberry and the color
pink were already
assigned to it
and it is displayed in the browser
itself
now that the constructor program is done
next let's see an example of how a
destructor works
let's open the code editor
create another file
destructor.php
now the destructor code will be very
similar to the constructor one so we
will copy the code
into the destructor file and make some
changes
so
let us remove this we don't need it
and write our destructor function
so destructive function is written
similarly
how constructor function is written
so it starts with two underscores and a
destruct keyword
it does not have an attribute
now why did we delete the get functions
is because we will be using the
destructor
for it
also we won't be needing this
just the object creation is sufficient
now let's save our program and
do the drill again
open the browser
here a destructor file is visible
and it shows the fruit is strawberry and
the color is pink so when the object
function is complete
and the program ends the destructor
function is called which displays the
strawberry and the color pink
now comes inheritance so it derives new
classes or child classes from the parent
class
however inheritance can have its own
properties and methods too so
inheritance has two classes
first is parent class and the other one
is a child class
now let's talk about each of them in
detail
so parent class is otherwise called a
base class that is inherited from
another class
and a child class is a subclass that
inherits from another class
a child class can have subclasses and
derived classes
now let's have a look at the inheritance
program
so the child class is derived from all
the properties and methods from the
subclass
in addition it can have its own
properties and methods too
so an inherited class is defined by
using the extends keyword
let's look at an example
let's open the code editor so i've taken
the liberty to create the
inheritance.php file
and write some of the code that we have
already written so i'll be writing only
the code that is necessary for the
inheritance part
now also remember when you derive a
child class from a parent class only the
public methods are derived into the
child class
so we will be creating the methods as
public
in order them to be
inherited
you
made this function public
let's
end this class
and create another class in order
to inherit this class
so we'll name
another class as
cherry
extends
fruit
and we'll create another function for
cherry so this function is exclusive to
cherry
so we have given a message through this
method
now
let's create an object
cherry
new cherry
and
give the values for the attributes
of
this constructor
let's save the code
and check if it's working
well there seems to be an error
now let's try to resolve it
okay got it so we
created the object
within
the cherry class so it got localized
what we need to do is put that code
outside of the cherry class
and it should work fine now
yes so is cherry a fruit or a berry
a cherry is a fruit and the color of the
fruit is red
and now we will talk about the last
concept that is polymorphism so
polymorphism has many forms
the same function is utilized for
different purposes
it has a class with a variety of
functions simultaneously sharing a
common interface
so inherited methods are overridden by
redefining the methods in the derived
class
now let me write the code to make it
clear
so i've already created the polymorphism
php file
i've copied the inheritance code
into the polymorphism part
and then now we'll make the changes into
the derived class that is cherry
so let's create a property named
vid
now to
override the constructor and the intro
function
from the fruit class we will have to
create the same functions
in the derived class also
now this function construct has got one
extra attribute in comparison to this
function construct
this
let's create the intro function too
now a code is ready
let us create another object
to invoke
the functions
now did you notice what we did here
so
when we created the object cherry
for the cherry class we gave three
attribute values instead of two
in order to invoke this construct
function
not this
let us run it and check
so it runs perfectly it displays the
fruit the color and the weight
in this video we will discuss some php
extensions that can be and should be
added in visual studio code to make php
programming a little easier and a life's
a little simpler
now to check the extensions available or
search any of them we need to go to this
tab that is the extensions tab
now
these are the already installed
extensions on our system
and from here you can search
extensions available in the visual
studio called marketplace
now the first extension and a must-have
extension is
php
intellifence
now to understand what it does
let me go back to
the explorer
and open a
test.php
so what i'm going to do is
write some
basic php built-in functions
let us say
php
info
so
what you need to notice is when you type
php info it shows a suggestion it is
from the built-in feature that is
already installed into the visual studio
code but when you click on this
that's it
now i'll show you the difference
go back to extensions
and install php intelligence
now go back to
your test file
and again
type php
info now as you can notice you can see
two php infos here now when you click on
this one you can see all the details
about this function
available
right here so this is what
php intellifence is it intelligently
suggests and autofills parts of your
code to make your programming simpler
and much easier
now moving on to a second extension our
second extension will be
php
mess detector
now what php mess detector does is it
analyzes your php code on every save
now there's no additional setup required
if php is already installed on your
system which already is
so to see what it does
let us install it
now before that let us go back to
test.php
and let me just
open this
now here you can see the output of your
code so if you go back to php mesh
detector install it
and go back to your code you can see php
mesh detector is visible here and after
everything
that you write
it analyzes your code after every save
and it is pretty useful while writing
big and complex php codes
now let's move on to the next extension
which would be
php
auto
close stack
now what php auto close tag as the name
suggests does is when you open a tag
when you whenever you write a tag that
is suppose html
or body etc etc anything that you write
it will automatically close the tag and
you can simply start writing the code so
this extension has saved me a lot of
time finding what problem is in my code
fixing the bug
when actually it was just that i did not
close the tag
so
suppose
i write html and as you can see it
automatically closes the tag and you can
simply start writing the code
now moving on to a next step that would
be
php fmt that is php formatter
now
what it does is it formats your code
with proper indentation and
well your code looks much more readable
after this
so
let me just show you
i've already created a test2.php
let me just close this
so as you can see
this code is not indented at all and
one might have trouble understanding
what is going on and what part of code
is under what
loops and
statements so
we go back to our extension php
formatter
install it
go back to test one
sorry test2
now when you right click
after installing this extension you can
see format document section available
then
when you click on it
the code gets automatically
indented and looks much more readable
now so
as you may notice
all these codes under comes under the if
conditions
and
that's the rest of the code looks much
more readable now
now the last extension that i'm going to
discuss
is php
debug
now this extension
you may not use it on a very regular
basis but this extension is very helpful
when you want to debug your code and see
what's wrong with it
all the instructions on how to use this
extension are written alongside it
and how to install how to use how to
install extra softwares in order to
completely utilize its potential
since this extension is a debug adapter
between visual studio code and x debug
website that was developed by derek
griffins
so
i'm going to install it
and this is the very website xdebug
the
any of your code is debugged
so
these are some of the extensions that
you need to begin or ease your journey
into php there are lot more extensions
available for php
and you can explore more into them as
you move forward
we will look at php in get and post
so all of us know that php is a
scripting language for creating web
pages but what is get in post
there are two ways the browser client
can send information to the web server
the get method and the post method
let's understand get method in detail
first the get method sends the encoded
user information appended to the page
request
the page and the encoded information are
separated by the question mark character
now let's know more about the get method
the get method produces a long string
that appears in your server logs in the
browser's location box
it is restricted to send up to 1024
characters only
also never use the get method if you
have a password or other sensitive
information to be sent to the server
since it will show in the browser's
location box
next the get can't be used to send
binary data like images or word
documents to the server
also the data sent by get method can be
accessed using the query string
environment variable
now let us try writing a code to
understand the get method better
so as you can see we have got the output
but if you look at the link
it has an ampersand symbol along with
the username and age we entered
now before the browser sends the
information it encodes it using a scheme
called url encoding
in this scheme
name value pairs are joined with equal
sign and different pairs are separated
by the ampersand
also
as we discussed earlier the page request
and the encoded information is separated
by a question mark sign
so that was all about the get method
moving on to the next one let's have a
look at the post method
now the post method transfers
information via http headers the
information is encoded and described in
the get method and put into a header
called query string
the pos method does not have any
restrictions on data size to be sent
the pos method can be used to send asci
as well as binary data and the data sent
by post method goes through http header
so security depends on http protocol
used by using secure http you can make
sure that your information is secure
now let's have a look at the code now
now you must be wondering if both the
methods give the same output so what is
the difference between them
well the major difference between post
and get method is that get method
carries request
parameters appended in url string as you
can see here the parameters are visible
in the url
while post carries request parameters in
message body which makes it more secure
way of transferring data from client to
the destination as you can see there is
no information in the url
now a lot of people have raised a
request to create a code on the request
method too
so let me tell you the request variable
can be used to get the result from form
data sent with both the get and post
methods
let us try out a code for the request
method too
as you can see we have got the output
today we will learn how to link mysql
database to your html code with the help
of php
now to do that we will build a simple
registration form whose data will be
uploaded to the mysql database and in
this tutorial you will learn how to
create that database how to link it to
your web page and also how to delete the
tables or entries from the database
now before proceeding i am expecting
that you guys have some basic
understanding of html php and mysql
so
without further ado
let's get started
also guys for this tutorial we will be
working on zam and visual studio code
now let's get started
so first we'll open the c drive xampp
folder
htdocs and let us create a
folder let's name it
tutorial
and
open the visual studio code and start
writing the code for a registration page
let's create a file
and name it index.php
let's give the title as registration
form
and close the head
now let's give
some
heading to a registration page
now to make it a little more interesting
let us suppose the registration page is
for a blood donation camp
we will
name our heading as the blood donation
camp
and
close it
now let's give some
background color
to the page
now to give
some background color we need to first
know the code for it
let's search for color codes
well i like the saffron one
let's copy the code
paste it here
and write div
a heading for the
page registration form
now as you can notice i wrote this
heading as h1 and this one has h2 since
this will be a little smaller from the
first one
let's close the div
and write a form
now
in this action part
write connect dot php and this is the
file which we'll be creating later in
order to connect our registration page
to the database
and method
as
post
let's name it user
so the first
entry would be
named
input type
would be
text
and we have to give
every entry a name
in order to use it in the php code to
connect to a database
let's give this name
name
now what i did here is i put the
required keyword here which would make
it compulsory in to
fill this
section of the form
in order to continue
i'm giving these break lines to
not make the form
clumsy
email so
naturally this would be the label for
email
and let me skip ahead with this section
so i have written the code
for the different fields that we are
going to have in a registration page
so the first one was name second email
third would be the phone number and
fourth obviously the blood group
of the person registering
as you can notice i have given necessary
type
for different fields so for email i've
given the type as email
for blood group text and phone as text
in case someone wants to enter the
entire phone number with the country
code
so now let us create an input button
that would be submit
and
name
let us keep it submit
id would be
submit
let's close our form
and close the
web page too
now let's save it and check
if it's working correctly
now let's open the browser
before that
first we need to open the sam control
panel and
start our apache server and mysql server
and now let us go to the localhost
type a folder name that is tutorial
and open the form
well there seems to be a problem the
other fields are not visible
let's open a code and see what did we do
wrong
yeah well there's a spelling mistake
here
and since i copy pasted the code
the mistake got copy pasted 2
well
let's save it again and check if it's
working correctly
yes perfect
now before moving on to creating our
connect.php file we first need to create
our database itself
so first we need to go to exam control
panel and click on admin
now this will open the php my admin
section
where
we will go to new
and create a database
let us name our database
as test one
let us give it five fields and name it
you
this
first field would be id
and it would be auto implemented
second we will name it as name
250
email
this will also be backer
third one would be
phone
variable characters since people can
enter the plus sign
to enter the
country goods
and finally we will have our blood
group
and let's create our
table here
well as you can see this is a structure
of the table and the table is created
now when you click on browse
it will show you the data in this table
itself since we haven't entered any data
yet it is blank
now let's
open up
code editor and create a file
connect
dot php
and
let's get started
now here we will have to enter
the name we gave to a submit button
and that would be submit
now we will create a variable to
create a connection and we'll be using
the mysqli
underscore
connect function to do that
[Music]
here we will have to enter the name of
the server since we our server is the
locally hosted server so we will have to
type localhost
now the
type of user that would be root
now the third part is for the password
since we don't have a password for a
database it would be blank
and the fourth would be the name of our
database that is test one
now we will also check
if connection
is not complete
we will have to display an error
connection field
now in this if condition we will check
if the entries in the fields
of the registration form
are null or not
we will have to do the same for the
second
second one was sorry i did not enter the
yeah
email
a third entry
was
phone
and a fourth and final entry would be
the blood group
i think we're done here
and
[Music]
now we will have to create
variables
to pick data from the
registration fields in a registration
page
now this post
will be picking data
what we'll be entering here
now here we will have to enter
the name
we have given
here
so for the name field we have given the
name as name itself so we'll be writing
it here
let's
copy this code
and make the changes
this would be email
let us also name it email
this would be
phone
this would also be born and
last one would be
blood group
because i am naming these variables same
as the name i've given because
naming everything differently would just
create confusion in your code
now let us enter these details into our
database now insert into sql command
now this would be
the table name
users
name
email phone
and
blood group
now we will have to
send the respective values
that would be the
variables that we just created
so first would be name
second would be email
[Music]
now that we have entered the
data into the database let's create a
query
to
connect it
with a command
and give a message if it's successful or
not
okay successful
else
error
occurred
let us close our php script here
and save the code
and let's see if it's working
so
let's go back to registration form and
give some
details to it
so
let us name
sam
sam at the rate
mail.com
phone would be one two three four five
six seven eight and the blood group can
be o positive
well there's some error that we've
experienced
on line four
okay
let's see
yeah we did not close this
okay
let's save it
and try again
another on line 12
what do we have here now
okay so this is my sql i not mysql
save
resend the form and entry successful now
the entry is successful you need to go
to your database
which i have shown to you earlier
go to the table users
and
we can see the details present here sam
sam at the rate mail.com the phone
number and the blood group
so now that we know how to create a
database link our database to a html
form
and see the details into the database
entered
we can also delete these details
from this php my admin section itself so
as you can see
to delete this field i just have to
click on this delete button
okay and the field is gone
also if you want to delete this users go
to your database
click on users and click on draw
what it will do is it will drop the
entire table
and if you want to delete your database
itself click on this database
icon
and click on drop the database
now this will remove the entire database
and all the tables associated with it
now let's enter
one more detail set of details to double
check it
let us give it mac
mac at the rate
mail.com that would be
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
and the blood group would be a positive
and the entry is successful
so to check it we need to go to our
database our table users
and there we have it math machad
mail.com and the
rest of the details today we are
discussing everything about tread
operators in php
let's begin with the definition first
trud stands for create
read
update and delete
these are the four fundamental functions
of persistent storage
these operators are used in creating
user interface conventions that help us
to view
search and modify data via computer
based forms and reports
basically the data is read built updated
and deleted
moving forward
let me talk about the purpose of these
operations one by one with the help of
demo codes
but first things first let's create a
database
to do that
open xampp control panel and start
apache and mysql
now let's quickly open our web browser
open the localhost and go to phpmyadmin
section
now let's
create a new database and
name it
my bb
let's name the table users and we will
have
six fields in it
the first would be id it would be
integer and auto incremented since it
would be the primary key
the second
would be
first name
type back here
let's give it 250
the third would be
last name
variable character
similarly
next would be an email
password
and finally
gender
so now that our table has been created
let's move on to the coding part
now first we are going to create a
file named config.php
to configure
the database
now we will create
variables
and i will explain the use to you
later
now this is the
default username for a localhost
now the default password for a database
is empty since there is no password in
our database
and the database name
would be my db
that's what we have named our database
now let's quickly create the connection
using
pawn variable
my sqli command
server name
username
password
and the database name
now this will create a connection
for our database
and now let's
also
check
for errors while creating the database
now if an error is found while
connecting to the database
it will show a message as connection
field
now let's end the file
and move on to understanding the
different credit operations
now first comes create
so let us also create a new file and
name it
create dot php
now the create procedure adds the insert
statement to create a new record now
let's write the code
for this
now what this line will do is it will
act as a link between the configuration
dot php file
and this create.php
to connect to the database
now
we are
checking if the submit button
on the form is pressed
now when the submit button on the form
will be pressed
the
fields are required to be sent to the
database
for that we first need to create
different variables
similarly
last name
these are the names that we have given
to
the
different sections in the table of our
database
password was password
and finally
gender
now let's write the sql query
insert into the name of the table that
is users
and now
we need to name
the
fields we are going to be entering the
details into
since id is auto implemented we are
going to be starting with first name
similarly last name
email
password
and
lastly
gender
now
these are the fields we are going to be
entering data into
now the values
would be
the variables that we just created which
are getting the data from the form using
the host function
into the variables
so name
similarly
last name
email
password
and gender
so
the code
to enter the
values into the database is complete
now let's also execute the query
[Music]
to do that
we will send the query using the connect
and
put the attribute as sql fields
now
if the records are created
it will display a successful message
else
in case of an error
it will
show a error message
now let's
close the connection
close function
and move on
to creating a html form
[Music]
let's give
a heading here
now this since this is a registration
page let's give the heading the signup
form
and create
the form
let's leave the action field as blank
and method
would be since we're using post
the method would be
post
[Music]
[Music]
now i'll just skip ahead with the sperm
part now as you can see i've completed
the code for the registration form which
will include the first name
last name password
and gender
now let's
save it
and move on to the next part
that is the view procedure
now the view procedure table records
data based on the primary key noted
within the input parameter
now let's create
another file
named
view.php for it and write its code
now i will run
the entire code in a single and
explain
how these different card operations are
working on the web page
now let's write the query
to get the data from the users table
from
users
now this will
retrieve all the data into from the
table
also let us execute the query
using
connect
query and pass
sql into it
and the php script
and write our
html
code
title would be
view
page
now i'm linking this page to a bootstrap
css document
to make it look
somewhat
stylish since basic html page looks
pretty boring
but to do that we are going to be
using the reference
and i have added the link for the css
file now let's
complete the
rest of the page
heading to this division
users
now this will also display the id from a
table
so we are going to be creating a
different set of
column
to display
the id
similarly
it will be the same
for the
address of fields so i'll just
copy this code
this will be for email
gender
and
[Music]
gender
and action
let's close it
next time
so this will check
there is data present in
our database
now if there is data
we are going to be
fetching the
same data
similar codes will be written
for the rest of the fields
so we will just
let me
just copy and paste
and change
the details
first name
last name
email
and
gender
you
uh
you
these are the codes for the edit and
delete commands
and finally
let us
close the page
now let's quickly move on to the
third part
update file
and write its
code
now
when the update button for the form is
clicked
we need
this code to process it
and similarly
for the rest of the fields
let's quickly change
user id
this would be id
last name
last name
all for variables are complete now let's
write the query
for the sql
update
name of the
table
users
and set
first
name
is equals to
first name
and similarly
for the rest of the code
now
let's execute the query
pass sql to it
again if
the record is a successful updation
pass successful message
and
if any error is occurred
we will give an error message for it
now if
id variable set in the url we need
we know that we need to edit a record to
do that
we will
again write a code
using get method
now we will write
sql command
to get the data
and
execute a query
okay
this is a very similar code to what we
have written earlier
to fetch the data if the number of rows
is greater than zero
it's
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
also skip ahead for the code
for this
update form
now this is the code for the update form
and now
last but not the least
we will
create the file
for delete
and write a code
very similar to how we have written the
rest of the quotes
let's write the sql query the same old
routine
so
as you guess i'm going to be skipping
ahead with some of the parts some part
of the code
now this is the code for our delete.php
file
and now
we will save all these files
and
go to a browser and try to run
check if they run correct now let's
open the localhost first and go to
phpmyadmin
and open our
choosers field here
so as you can see i've already created a
record here i'll create another one to
show you how
for that let's go to localhost
demo
and
go to create.php
so second record let's name it mac
x
simply learn
b
now the email would be map x at the rate
simply learn
b dot com
password
and
submit new record created successfully
now let's refresh it
and as you can notice we have created
another record here
now
let's go
to localhost again
and
what was our next operation for crud it
was c create
our
read that would be view.php now view.php
displays both of the records that we
have saved
in our database
now
these number differences would be
because i have created and deleted two
more records before recording this part
of the video
now
let's go
to
edit section of any of this record
so
as you may notice it opens the
update.php file
user update form
also the thing to notice is that it
refers to the id that we are updating in
the url itself
now since we clicked on the edit part
of the first field
it is updating the first field itself
now let's update this
miss
xxx
abc at
xyz.com
and update
record updated successfully now let's
check the record
and yes the record is updated
now
since we are done with the two parts
create
read
and even the third part update cru now
let's move on to the d that is deleted
let's go to the delete
for that we would have to
go to the
view.php itself
now
let us delete this
second field mac x simply learn b mac x
addressing lnb.com
delete
now
you may notice the url delete dot php id
4 now id equals 4 is deleted from the
database
let's check
and yes the file from the database has
been deleted
so
this is how we perform our thread
operations with the help of php and
mysql database
today we are going to have a video
session on php form validation
so what does this actually mean
okay well let me give you an example
here so when you try to create an
account on facebook or instagram you
submit a form and then that form is
cross verified with the code written in
the backend
so today we are going to do the same
process in this video
now we will have a look at two demos now
in the first demo we will create a form
and in the second one we will validate
it
so let's get started with the first demo
but first things first
let's quickly open
c drive xampp folder htdocs and
create a folder
let's name it validation
and open our code editor here
and let's create a first file
form dot php
now i'm going to write the code for the
registration form
you
now here what we are doing is we are
creating the different variables for the
form
and we are setting it to empty values
let me put that in a comment too
this
okay
okay
now as you can see the
form will contain full name email
number comment gender and age
now for this demo the username
email and mobile number fields will be
text input elements while the comment
field will be a text area
let's write the next rest of the
now we are defining the
test input function which we are calling
in the above if statement
you
let's start creating the form
and add the method to
post
action would be
okay
okay
so i skipped ahead and created all the
details
required in the form so the details
would be full name
its input type
would be text
uh just
yet
okay now
um second would be email similarly
number
h comment now notice the comment would
be a text area instead of a simple input
type
gender
and a submit button
now the form is complete
we have to write another php script to
display the details
[Music]
i'll just skip ahead in this part too so
now that we can display all of the
variables from the form let's close
the php script
and also
close our
form
now let me explain some parts of the
code to you before we move on to
the webpage part
so
here we have
post
so this function is used at the time of
form submission now during that time the
form data is sent with
method
equals to post
second would be the server section
now this server php self is a global
variable that returns the file name of
the code
now also html special characters
function converts special characters to
html entities now this prevents
attackers from exploiting the code by
injecting html or javascript codes
that is cross site referencing scripting
attacks in forms
so now that we know what these functions
do
let us jump and see if a webpage works
okay
for that first open sam control panel
and start the apache server
and now let's open the browser
and type localhost followed by the
folder name that would be validation
and then a file name form.php
so yes the form looks good let's
add some name to it
email
xyz.com
number is optional but let's add some
number to it
it would be 20
comment would be
hello
welcome to
simply learn
gender would be male and let's click
here
yes so our input is visible and the form
works perfectly
now let's move on ahead with a second
demo that is validating a form
now we will be writing a code but with
slight variations now the fields like
full name email address and websites
will be added here and these three
fields will show an error if an
incorrect input is given
now however the code is validated
against the input and returns an alert
message if an incorrect data is center
let's go to the code editor
and create another file
and let's name it
validate.php
and write
another code for it
now added some color for the
error that will be shown into the
form
again
let us write comment for it define
variables
and
set to
empty
and our variables would be named err
that is error
similarly email
error
gender
trr
and the rest of fields
i'll skip the else command for it
now if
no error found or the field entered is
correct
the name will be displayed as we
displayed the name in the form.php file
with the help of post
name
now what we are going to do is now we
will check if name only contains letters
and white spaces
a
you
and this would be
er
now we will check
if the email address is well formed or
not
to do that we will again use an if
statement
this
i think i have used
emi somewhere
since it's showing here emai
so let's check before it throws an error
in a code
there's email yeah
okay we made a mistake here so this else
was not supposed to be closed here
let's move it ahead
yeah i think
this looks good
let's
write
another code for
another variable
that is
website
and do the same thing again
website
now we will check if the url address
syntax is valid or not
so
let's just be assembling
you
do
now we will write the
test input function as we did
in the form section so let's just
copy it from there since it's going to
be the same
now let's write
the php
script
for the form
validation section
home method would be post
action would be
php script again
you
i'll just skip ahead with this part of
the program
so now that we have a complete form here
let's
close it
as you can see we have entered full name
email address website comments and
gender parts to the form
now let's write a final php script to
display the details
since this will also be similar to the
last part
we will just copy it from there
and make the necessary changes
so
[Music]
what we don't have is
full name this would be just name
email
and this would be
website
there's no number
it's deleted
there's a comment and there's a gender
let's close the script
and also close our
webpage
now let's save the file
open a browser and check if our web page
is working correctly
type localhost the name of the folder
and the name of your file
okay
so let's write something mac
mac xyz
now let's not write something after it
so that the email address would be wrong
just to check
one two three
dot
c
comment
anything would do
gender mail and let's click on submit
so as you can see
it shows enter a valid website url and
the email address is incorrect
let us also check by writing
an incorrect name that would be mac1
email address
mac xyz at the rate and 123.c
now it's showing the error for the name
too
okay let's write something that is
correct
mac
address gmail.com
website would be www dot simply
comment could be anything
mail
and no errors here
as you can see we have got the output
in this video we will learn how to
create a registration page using php
html some css and xampp software
then
we will use that data and store it in a
mysql database
so
let us begin and start writing a code
first
now to do that
we need to go to my computer c drive
now xampp folder this is the folder
where the xampp software is installed
here
locate to htdocs
and let us now create a folder for our
tutorial and
name it tutorial
now we'll open this folder in visual
studio code
and start writing a program
so let us create a first file here and
name it
register
dot
html now this will be the html file that
is the whole structure of how a
registration page will look
now
[Music]
registration
page now this will be the title
of our web page
i think that's enough
now let us move on to the
body of the page
now i'm going to write
register
in an h1 point
for the heading
and
now will create a form
action would be
the name
register.php
and method
or tree
post
okay so
the first label that i'm going to create
will be for the username
so in a registration form i'm going to
keep it simple i'm just going to include
three categories that would be username
password and a third one would be email
so
to create the label for
username
so you always have to keep in mind
whatever name you are giving here or in
the database whichever you write first
since the name has to match
so i'm giving username the name username
and that's it for a label
now let us create another label
for
before that
input type for this
will be
text
name as we've already written
will be username
please holder with display
user name
and i'm going to put this field as
required
which means that the
user cannot leave this field empty
second one would be
label 4 password
now i am going to give its input type
as
password
and you'll know the reason later
you can also give input type for the
password as text but it will not be
secure then
password
id will be
password
and this is also a required field
now let us move on to
the label
for our last section that will be email
and
give its
input type
email
yes and email can be set as an input
type
name email
placeholder will display
email
and you guessed it right this is also
a required field
i think
this is it for the registration html
now we move on to
creating our
css page in order for this html
structure to look good
well wait a second i left off of a
pretty important section of the
registration form that is the register
button itself
so
let me just
not form
let me just create
the
registration
for
registration button
and will be of type submit
and value
displayed would be
register
now we'll move on to creating the css
file
and
let us create a new file and name it
style.css
so the code for style.css is already
prepared so instead of writing the
entire code line by line i'm just going
to paste it
and
you can see how it works
so this is the css code that will make
a registration form look a little better
so i have created different sections
for different sections of the
registration form so this will be the
registration from input button
this is for the color of the
submit button
and
the rest of the form as you can see
now in order for the style.css file to
work
we need to link this file
style.css to register.html
now how do we do that
we go on to the register.html
back
and we add
just
one extra line in the head of the
program
so
here what we're doing is we are
referencing our style.css page into this
page itself
now that's it
now both of these pages that we've just
created are linked to each other and now
at least a registration form
structure is complete
it does not work yet but it will soon
now before creating the register.php
code
let us first create a database
so that we have some understanding of
what is going on around everything so to
create a database what we need to do is
open xaml
start the apache and mysql server
now go to your browser
and open the localhost phpmyadmin
now create a new database
let us name it
form
click on create
now let us name our table as users
number of columns would be four
the first column will be id
which will be auto incremented
second will be username
make sure to use the same name that
we've used in the code
so that
the code does not malfunction
it will be of type
variable character
password
will also be a variable character
email
and now
so as you can see this is the structure
of our
table
of database form
now let us move on to finally writing
the
rest of the code for our registration
form
so now that we have a database complete
let us move on to our back to our code
and create a register.php file
now the first thing that we need to do
while creating the php code is
we need to
connect our code with our database that
we just created so this is why i stopped
in between and created a database so
that you need
you understand better how this code is
functioning
now database host
since
we are using sam to locally host a
server
this will be
localhost a user will be the root user
since we have not set any password on
the database it will be empty
and finally
the name of our database
what did we name a database
it was form
now i will create
a variable con
to
connect
to connect a database
with our code
so we have created host
user password
and finally
name
now
we have got to add an error message
which will check
if
the database is
connected or not
so
will be
[Music]
error
connecting to the database
now let us add some code
to check if any variable
is
empty or not
okay
up
now if any of the field is left empty
while filling the registration form it
will display the following message empty
field
now
let us add another
code and check
do
so now that we have added validation
into a code
now what we need to do next is
check
whether the username or the details that
have entered that the user has entered
the registration form already exists or
not
and if it does
display an error message and if
the details are new enter the details
into our database
now to do that
let us write another if statement
now here i am writing
an sql command which will
select
id
password from users that is the name of
a table
where username and
here we are going to check if the
username entered still exists or not
take
now if the number of rows is greater
than 0 which means username already
exists so we need to display
an error message that would be username
already
exists
try
again
and if it does not
now in this else part we will be writing
the code
for to send our data into the database
now here
instead of selecting we are going to
insert the data into
users which is a table
and
the fields will be username
password
email
and that's it
now the password
variable is going to fetch
the details
of the password field
that
and email
add another statement
to
execute
and display
another message now since we have
entered it into the database we need to
display
a following message too
this would do
now
[Music]
this will display
an error message in case something goes
wrong
and now
since we have completed this part of the
code
let us end a statement
you
close the connection with the database
here and end our php script
so now that our code is complete now let
us run
the code and check if it works fine
so
our apache server is running
let's go back to our browser
open the localhost name of the folder
so as you can see register pages are
visible here
register.html
and create
a user
tony
at the rate
aaron
and dot com
you have successfully registered and you
can now login
so
let us now check
if it's visible in our database
so our database is
forms
users
and as you can see the
file that we just created tony
is visible here in a database
along with the email and
one thing that you may notice is that
the password is not visible here since
we use the hash protection for passwords
so passwords will not even be visible to
the
database admins
so this is how you create a registration
form with the help of html php exam and
mysql database
in this tutorial we'll create a simple
login system using php and mysql now
this tutorial is comprised of two parts
in the first part we'll create a login
form and in the second part we'll create
a local also we will show you how to
create a database in order to access the
login web page as well now first things
first let us quickly go to c
zam htdocs and create a folder let's
name it demo and quickly open our visual
studio code now for this tutorial we'll
be creating a set of files for different
functions now there will be six in total
let us first create these files and
we'll write the code later now the first
file would be
index.php now this is the file that will
be responsible for the login page where
we will enter a username and password to
login now the second file would be
login.php
now this file will be responsible for
how our login system will work similarly
there will be a logout file that will be
responsible for how our logout function
will work next
would be
home.php now this is the file for our
home page when we login into our account
next would be a file to link our web
page to the database that would be
database connection dot php and finally
we'll add a css file to make the page
look better now let's get on to writing
a code first let's begin with index.php
now in this page we will create
the login page
let's
add the title
as login
now here i'm going to link this page to
the css file that we are going to write
later
now in this reference
we'll refer it to the style.css file we
created
let's create a form
now since
login.php is responsible for how our
login page will work we will link this
index.php to login.php
method would be
post
let us add a heading
login
now this part of the code will be
checking for error and displaying error
if
something wrong happens
now we will
add our
username and password fields
let's add another label for password
input type would also be password
now let us
add the
login button
it would say
login
and our form here now our index.php code
is complete now let's move on to
login.php
and
write its code
now what we are going to do is we are
going to connect this page with the
database page
now here
we will be validating the data
entered in the form
let us
create a variable
for username and password
make sure not making any spelling
mistakes otherwise
you will run into errors
now
what this code is doing
is it's checking if there's an entry in
the username and password field and if
it is empty it will display the message
as username is required
similarly what we are going to do is
we are going to create an elsif
that would check if the password field
is empty
and display an error message
in a similar way
now that is set up let's import our data
from a database now we have not created
the database yet but
we'll write the sql query and we'll
create a database later now what i'm
going to do is i'm going to name my
table as users so here i'm writing
select star from users where
user name
would be
the
value we passed and similarly
password
would also be the value that we
passed
now this is where if the password and
username match with what we have in a
database it will display a message as
logged in
now we are going to create a session
that would be a login session
now id will also be a field in a
database that would be auto incremented
and work as the primary key
okay if function is complete
time to write the else part
now the else part would be if the
username
or password you have entered does not
match with the one we have in a database
so it would display incorrect username
or password as the error message
location will be same index.php
so now we have our login.php file also
complete now let's get on to our
home.php file and quickly write the code
for it we will start the session
now this
would be our home page
let us also
link it to the
css file
tile dot
css
now
with this php script we will display
the username of the person that's logged
in so suppose my username would be mac
so it would display hello mac we will
very
soon see the practical demo for it too
now we will link this home page with the
logout session that is
logout.php
and
end this
okay so home.php is also complete so
next would be to work on the lower part
now this is a very small code since it
is only working to in any session that
has been created
now first unset the session
and
then
destroy it
now can you guess the location
it would be
index.php now see this is all the code
for the logo file now finally we will
move on to database connection file
where we will connect our entire web
page these entire four files to the
database
so we are going to create variables for
let us name it since we have already
used unnamed for username now this is
the name for the server and since we are
hosting a server locally it is localhost
now the next variable would be for the
name of the
okay let us let us change the spelling
this would be name of the default
database
password would be blank since by default
there is no password
and
this is the name of the database that we
are going to keep now
let us keep the name of our database as
test underscore database
now we'll pass
the variables
that we just created
now
we will check if the connection that we
have created is
working or not and if not we will
display a message as connection failed
now all of our files are complete the
only thing left is
style.css now since style.css is only
for the looks of the of the webpage and
is not a very necessary file for our
login function i will just copy paste
the code that i have already written and
let us now move on to creating a
database now to do that first open xampp
control panel and go to your browser
and type
okay
localhost go to phpmyadmin
and click on
new database now
the name that we wrote for the database
in our code was test underscore db so we
will have to name it the same here too
database has been created the table name
would be users number of columns would
be three the first column would be
for the id and it will be auto
incremented now id will act as also the
primary key for this table second would
be user
name
100 would be okay
and
third would be password now as you can
see our table users has been created
with id username and password now
let us
open
our
login page now this is our login page so
to login we first need some credentials
in the database now we don't have that
kind of time to go on and create a
registration page for it too so let us
just manually add
one or two records into the database
from here phpmyadmin itself so now what
we are going to do is we are going to
this insert section and under the
username
let us type mac
and password would be one two three four
five so let's go back to browse and as
you can see we have a credentials here
map password is one two three four five
so
let's add just one other
simply learn its password would be abcde
and
yes so we have both of our credentials
now
now
let's go to the login page and try to
login with the credentials that we just
created so
okay let us first enter a wrong password
to check if our error messages are
working correctly
yes absolutely so it's showing incorrect
username or password since the password
i entered was incorrect now let us leave
this username blank
and some random password so it is
showing username is required so our
program is working perfectly now let's
enter the correct credentials
and yes so this is our home page and it
is showing hello with the username that
have logged in mac and now we have got
that logout button which will end this
session and take us back to the login
page now let's try to
login to a second account
and hello simply learn we will learn
what is rest api with php
now let's get started
now suppose you want to create a weather
app for weather forecasts in your area
now to do that you have to set up a
supercomputer and a satellite to monitor
the real-time weather
but i wish everyone could be that rich
now for those who cannot afford the
setup you can get the same information
from an existing web service using an
api
now an api acts as a medium between a
web service and your application which
helps you communicate your requests with
the service and get a response
so in this video we'll be learning about
what is rest api
principles of rest api
how does a rest api work and finally
creating a sample rest api with the help
of php
now let's move on and see what exactly
is res api
api stands for application programming
interface
now api is a set of protocols which acts
as a medium of communication between
programs
in other words it is a way two programs
talk to each other now let us understand
this with an example
suppose you
the client go to a restaurant to eat now
here the restaurant is supposed to be
the server
how do you communicate your order to the
kitchen
here the waiter comes in the picture
now here the waiter acts as a medium
between you the client and restaurant
the server to send your request to the
kitchen and get food in return as per
requested this is exactly what an api
does
so now that we have an understanding of
api let us look at what res means in
rest api
now res stands for representational
state transfer
it is an architectural style which
defines a set of protocols of how an api
is written
now
rest follows a set of principles for the
design and development of an api
now it is a very efficient technology as
rest takes less bandwidth over similar
other technologies
so now that we know what res api is let
us move on to understanding the
principles on which a rest api is
designed
now the first principle is client server
the second stateless
third cacheable
both uniform interface
fifth layered system and sixth code on
demand
now let us understand these principles
one by one
client server a res api design works on
the concept that the client and server
should be isolated from one another
and develop independently
this helps in increasing manageability
across various platforms
stateless now according to this
principle rest api should be stateless
which means calls can be made
independent of one another
also every request sent from the client
to the server must include all the info
needed to comprehend the request
cachable
this principle states that a rest api
should be able to hold cacheable data
the data and the response should be
indirectly or directly categorized as
cachable or non-cacheable
uniform interface
according to this principle there should
be a uniform interface across all
devices and platforms for the
interaction between application and
server
layered systems now res api's
architecture includes several layers
that operate together to construct a
hierarchy that helps generate a more
scalable and flexible application
due to the rest api layered system the
application has better security as
components in each layer can not
interact outside the subsequent layer
moreover it balances loads and offers
shared caches for stimulating
scalability
now the last code on demand now this is
optional but this principle allows for
coding to be communicated through the
api as executable code to the client to
be used within the application
we now know on what principles an api is
designed now let us see how an api works
rest api makes use of http methods to
implement various tasks based on the
client risk request
so the http method uses grid to perform
various operations on the server
crud here stands for create
read
update and delete
now in case of http methods post method
is used to create
get method to read data
put method to update it and delete
method to delete data
so i hope you have some understanding of
what risk apis are
principles on which they are designed
and how do they work
now let us move on to creating a sample
risk api with the help of php
so first let us open
the zam
control panel
and start our apache and mysql servers
now what i am going to do is i am going
to
create
a database
for my api
let us name it api
and let us name the
table as users
it will have four columns
first one would be id integer and it
will be auto incremented
the second let us name it as name
[Music]
third would be
age
and finally
email
now name would be a text and email will
also be a text
let us quickly save this
and now we have a table for us
now let us add some data into the table
so
mac
it would be 21 email would be mac
address xyz.com
now let us create another entry
name could be simply learn
age
30
email
simply learn
xyz.com
now as you can see we have added two
rows
with the data that we just entered
now let us move on to the visual studio
code and
see
exam
htdocs
and
let us create a new folder let's name it
api
and
open with visual studio code
let's create a new file
let us name it tutorial
[Music]
dot php
and now let us start writing our
code
now first what i'm going to do is i'm
going to connect
my database
with this code
now since the database is locally hosted
it will be local first
root
since there is no password
this field has to be empty
now
what was the name of a database that is
api that is what we have to enter here
now this is a variable
to get the response from the server
for the database
okay there's something wrong
now it seems like my
opening curly braces key is not working
so i had to open
this on-screen keyboard
we don't need you
right now
now let us create
another variable named sql
now this is select this command will
select
all the data
from our table users
users
again we are going to need the curly
braces
what i'm doing here is i am creating a
variable
as a counter and i am going to
give it a value of 0.
now let us create a while
loop
and in this while loop
i am going to
fetch the data
and display it in json format
uh
now we are going to write the names of
all the
rows that we created in a table
i'm just going to
copy paste it otherwise we'll have to
use this on-screen keyboard again and
again
second one was
named
agent email
now what i'm going to do is
i will
plus plus the counter
now to display it as an in json format
we have to write
this in encode
with the response
error message and now let us
end the
code
let us go and quickly
save a code
open a browser
go to the localhost api
this is the folder that we created
now as you can see our tutorial.php is
visible here and when you click on it
you can see the data from the database
being
extracted
with the help of api in json format
in this video on php web development we
will learn how to create a website with
the help of php
we'll also be using html css bootstrap
and mysql in this tutorial
so get ready to create your very own
website
now before we get started with the
step-by-step tutorial let me give you a
glimpse of the website that i'll be
building in this video
so let me just quickly go to my browser
and type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder where i have created
the website
so i'll be making a photo gallery
website like this
so in case you're a photographer you can
build a similar website in order to
showcase your talent
and if not you can always create your
own personal website for anything you're
passionate about
so
without any further delay
let's get right on to a tutorial
so first things first let me show you
the environment that we'll be working on
while creating a website
so we are going to be needing
two softwares that
is visual studio code that we'll be
using as our id the code editor
and the second one would be
xampp
now zamp is a web server solution
package which we generally use in order
to manage a database and create a local
web server
you can download it from these
respective websites
since i've already downloaded downloaded
both of these softwares so
we'll be skipping that
now
let us begin so
after that you've installed both of
these surface just go to your
c drive
locate xampp folder
and inside the jump folder look for
htdocs
and inside this htdocs
name a folder you can name it anything
i'll be naming it photo since i'm
creating a website regarding photos
and then right click inside this folder
and click on open the code
so this opens up our visual studio code
and as you can see our photo folder is
visible
here now also one thing that we need to
do is
go back to this photo folder
right click
and create two new folders first one
would be css so it's considered a good
practice even if you're using a single
just a single css file it is considered
a good practice to create a separate css
folder inside your project folder
also
create another folder
and name it images so this is where
we'll be keeping all the images for the
website
so let us go back to visual studio code
so as you can see both of these folders
are now visible here now
go on and click on new file
the first file that we are going to
create is index.php
and inside this index.php will be
writing the code for the main page of a
website
so let us start
first
click on an exclamation mark
and as you can see a block of code
already written is
visible here now
so
we just need to add a few things
first
let us
put the title the title would be
of
course go to
gallery
next up
we need to add a few links to our
webpage in order for it to function well
so the first link
would be
this is a link to
link this page to
bootstrap
you can also easily find it on the
internet
or you can just
type in from here
let me just go to the browser to check
if this link is working
yeah
seems fine to me
now we are going to add
another
link to it
now this link
will be for the link for a css file that
we'll be creating later on
since we'll be
putting that css file inside a css
folder
i am going to
link it to
style.css
so that's it
we are done for the first part of a code
now let's
end this head section
and
move on to the body section of our web
page
so inside this body section what we
first need is
to add a few scripts
for our page which will be responsible
for the design of our webpage
so
these are the three scripts
that i'll be linking to a webpage you
can just
look and
write them as it is
also keep these three scripts at the end
of your
body so
any code that will be writing inside
body will be above these three scripts
now let's
design the webpage
so the first thing that we'll be needing
is a navigation bar in a web page so let
us quickly go to the browser
so instead of writing an entire big
block of code
we can just copy it from the internet
so
bootstrap provides
you with many such designs so what we
are going to do is we will type in
navbar
bootstrap
and hit enter
so as you can see
just
scroll down and as you can see this is
the navigation bar
which this code will display
also
there are different navigation bars
according to your need
along with the code so you can just
copy any of the one you like i'm going
to be copying this one
click on copy
go back to the code and
just paste it
so now what we have here is our
navigation bar ready
so
let us go to the browser and check
how does our web page look
so after the local host what we're going
to do is we will write the name of the
folder in which we are writing a project
which is photo
well there seems to be some
problem since this
nav bar is lacking the css design let us
go back to our code and see
what went wrong
well yes this css file that we linked
here after css there is not a dot but a
flash
i think it should work fine now
well
the problem still persists
let me go back and recheck
well yeah i've made some spelling error
here
this is bootstrap not board strap
and let us go back
reload
and yes as you can see our navigation
bar is
well and good
let's go back and make some changes to a
navigation bar the first change that i'm
going to be making is i will
change the color theme of the nav bar
to
dark note mark
go back
reload
and looks better
now
here auto gallery
good
also
since i'll be using the drop down menu
it is absolutely up to you if you want
to use it or not
since i'll be using it i'll just change
the
name
to
categories
and the three category
will be
the first is
nature photo photographs
the second would be
architecture
and the third
would be
travel
so let's go back
refresh categories nature architecture
and travel so this travel looks a little
different from this nature and
architecture
so as you can notice this this line that
is dividing
this section to this section
so
let's go back so
that line
comes from this part of the code so
we'll just copy
and paste it here
looks good
now
that we're back we don't need
this
disabled
and the search file
so i'll be removing
that
particular part of the quotes
and this form2
go back to the browser refresh
and
all of the parts of the
navigation bar that we don't need are
now have now been removed
also this link
would be
for
about section of the webpage and we will
also add another section or another link
that would redirect us to the contact
part of the webpage so to do that to add
another link we will just copy this code
and paste it
and instead of about
this will be contact
go back
refresh
home contact about categories so this
categories should come before
these two
so
what we're going to do is we will just
copy this section of the code
and put it after the drop down menu
right
now go back
refresh
until we copied it instead of
cutting it
so
it's now visible twice
reload
home categories contact and above
looks perfect
so you see now that's the beauty of
building a website you don't have to
write the entire code by yourself
there are
codes already written for all these
kinds of stuff this navigation bar the
carousel that i'm going to be using in
the website the blocks of photos that we
are going to display
on the web page and a lot of design
templates you can call them have already
been written for you to use them instead
of wasting your time and writing the
entire long blocks of code
now next up what i'm going to do is i'll
just go back
to our
photo folder
and inside this images
i'll just
copy the images that have already
downloaded
copy
to back
images
and paste it here
so now that we have our photos inside
the images folder
let's go back to our code and
write
a carousel code or just copy it from the
bootstrap
go back to bootstrap
here
look for carousel
so as you can see
this is what a carousel looks like so a
big
photo
in
on the front of your web page as you
already saw when i showed you the
website
these are the different types of
carousels available on the bootstrap
website
you can use any of them
so
the first one is just a single photo
second one
is slides of photos
third is slides photos with this marking
and the final one would be all of them
combined with captions so of course
we'll be using the final one
so copy the code for the final
carousel or whichever one you like and
go back to your code
and here
after this navigation bar
your character code
click on save
go back
and refresh
so
since we haven't added any images here
there are none visible but you can see
this
carousel has been added to our webpage
so
let's go back and now we are going to
add the images that we just
pasted in this images folder
so in this carousel code
look
for
image src so this is the location
of the image that will be displayed
so
type in images that is the name of the
folder from where you will be picking up
the images
for slash and
let me just
go back to this images architecture or
yep
so architecture for
in this alt
type in
architecture and here
is the heading so this is part of the
caption
of the
carousel
so
i'll be writing okay texture
here and i'll make this heading a little
bigger
it's three i think h3 would do
and i don't want to add any more
descriptions if you do you can write all
of that inside this paragraph
but
i won't be so i'll just remove it from
here
i'll do the similar
with
this
so
what we're going to do is we will write
images
slash
and go back
what image i'm going to be adding nature
4 would do
nature
or
type in
nature
similar
to what we did
above
h3
h3
remove this
and now
here the last one would be
travel
h3
h3 and
let me just
type in the
travel five
travel
five
and in this alt
type
travel
and we are good to go
okay let's reload
and voila so our
images are visible here with this
beautiful carousel
and you can forward them and
well
does this not look beautiful to you
so architecture
nature
and travel
but
as you can see we have some problem here
the images are way too big to fit on
this part of the screen
and it's going all the way down
and this part of the carousel is not
visible on the main page when someone
opens the website which absolutely does
not look good
so
what we're going to do for it
now to fix this what we're going to do
is we will go back to our code editor
inside the css folder
we will create the file that we linked
at the start of our tutorial style.css
and
here
just
write this code
margin
0
adding also 0
and
box sizing
would be border box
so
now
to display the images
on the
just on the main page of our website
what we're going to do is we will
put a dot go back to the
main index.php and from here
copy this name of the class carousel
item
go back to style.css
paste it here carousel item
and type img
and inside this
we will define the width
and the height of the image so the width
would be 100
and we are going to keep the height at
95 we h so that it does not go beyond
the webpage
let us quickly save it
go back
reload
and yes it looks great
and
it's also visible on our screen now
now next up what we're going to do is we
will be creating different sections on
this very web page
for the different categories that is
nature architecture and travel
so
go back to the code
under this
carousel code
let us start writing our first section
that would be
section
class
so
i'll be using
my four and by four
the first
div
so what we want is we want the text to
be in the center of the page so
the class would be text center
and
the first category is nature
now the next thing that we need to do is
we need to add the images to it so how
do we do that
also we are
not to display a single image
on a
on the entire web page what we need is
we need to display small
three blocks of images in a row
so
we
need to create another div
class
and inside the class
we will define the column
for
large
systems
for the
mid ones
and
for the mobile devices
so
after you've written this class after
you've written this div
the images
doesn't matter the size of the screen
only
three images will be displayed on a
large and middle screen and a single
image will be dis visible when open on a
mobile phone so
all in all your website will be very
responsive to all the
devices that you will be using
let's just close it and inside this tip
what we're going to do is
we will link our
image
and
the image
would be
since this is nature
let's use nature1
which image would give we have already
used in the carousel
nature 4 so let's skip that
and
put the class as
fluid
and padding bottom padding would be
three
well
i think
it's
done
so this is the
first section let's go to our page
refresh
so nature and our first image is also
visible here so what we need is we need
to display two more images in this row
go back
and it's now all copy and paste
just
not this part
this part of code
copy
paste
and paste
so
now
nature to
and nature three
go back
refresh
okay there seems to be a problem here
let us figure out why this is happening
okay we forgot to add the
road if
and without the road if the images will
not be displayed in a row
but of this
so
container
fluid
i'm using this
since
just a second
let me paste it here
yeah
and
we will create another div
named row
and
our entire code will go inside it
and we'll paste it
let's go back and check if it changes
anything
and it does so our images are displayed
perfectly
our first section that is nature for our
categories is complete now now next what
we need to do is
i think you guessed it
we just need to copy this section
and paste it
twice
since there are two more sections
so after the first section
in the second one would be
for
architecture
the images we need to change
architecture one
architecture two
and
architecture three
yeah
refresh
nature architecture
and well nature again because we did not
edit the third part of the code
so the third part of the code
will be for
travel
let us quickly
add the images
so travel to
travel 4
and i
think we use travel
5 already
so
travel six
and go back
refresh
and travel images architecture and
nature so
half of our website is already done guys
now
what we need to do is we need to create
two more sections for the contact and
about
so
for the contact part of the webpage we
will be needing a form that we will then
go on and
link to a database that we'll be
creating later on
and the about section will be
responsible to
give
some information regarding the website
regarding the
photographer that have uploaded the
images
so
let's go back to our code and
move on to creating another section for
the contact
so
wait let me just copy only
this section
of the code
and of course
we'll be needing a closing tag
this will be
contact
us
and
let's
create another div
class would be
50
and m
auto so
why i'm doing this is because
inside the contact will be creating a
form
where there will be columns
and to manage the width and
margin of these columns i am writing the
class for it
inside this tip
we will write a form
inside the form the first thing that we
need is action
and the action for the form
will be
about
dot php this is a file that we'll be
creating later on
and the next thing is method
which will be post
let's close this
create another div
class named
form
group
okay
from group
close it
inside this
i'll write a label
that would be
name
this will be our first column input
type
text of course
let's give it a name so this is very
important so the name that you're going
to write here
should be
matching should be matching with the
name in the database
and class
from
control
now
just copy this
paste
and
paste
so the second section would be for
email
type will also be
email
name will also be
email
third would be for the number
let us keep the type text in case
someone wants to enter the
sud codes
and let's go back
refresh
check
contact us the fields are visible now
what we need is a submit button
so after this step
let me
create a button
type
submit
class
so this
will make the button look
green adding some
css
and
the button would be called submit
go back refresh
submit button is here
now
let us also create a section for the
about part of the page and then we'll
move on to
making a database
so to do that what we need to do is
we'll just copy this section
for the about
paste it here
close the section
and here
let's
start writing the code
the class
container
fluid so why are we using this container
fluid class is because sometimes when
you don't use
this class the images or text from your
web page tends to
create
so you can see a scroll bar here
vertically it tends to create another
scroll bar
horizontally which we don't want
so container fluid
close the step
inside it
let me create a class
text
center
it will say the name mac
we just give some space
and
write a paragraph
with a class of course
text
center
otherwise if the text will start from
the extreme left it would look weird
and
close it
let's add some bold
and right
let's see
i am
passionate
photographer
interested
in
working
architecture
nature and
travel
photography
next
would be
um
[Music]
full-time
freelancer
with an
experience of
five
yes
well i think this would do
refresh
oh we did not change this we'll just get
right on to it
contact us i'm a passionate photographer
interested in working architecture
nature travel photography
freelancer and all of the things that we
just written about mac
we just need to change this
to
about
and i think we're done
yes
so
our web page is almost complete guys
now we need to do some
changes
or add some things so the first thing
that we'll be adding is
an
about.php
file
and inside this about.php file we will
be creating a connection with our
database
and fetching the data from it
or sending the data from our form to the
database
so before that
let's go back
to the browser type in localhost
followed by php
my
admin
click enter
but before that
you must
open xampp control panel and start the
apache server and mysql server since i
already did i did not show you the steps
so after the mysql server has been
started you can see this phpmyadmin
panel and from here we can create
databases
so inside this phpmyadmin
click on new
and let us name our database as
graphy
click on create
now what we are going to do is we will
create a table
where the data
will be stored from our form
let us name the table as users number of
columns would be four
the first column would be
course id
which will be auto incremented
the second column would be name
type variable character
250
third is
email
also
variable character 250
and the final was our number
variable character 250
and
click on save
so as you can see the structure of our
table
the table users have been created inside
the database photography
now we need to go back to our code
and write the code php code to connect
our form
to this database
so first variable that i'll be creating
is
con to connect
the database
since a server is locally hosted the
name of the server would be
localhost
root
that is the default
now if connection
so this
if condition will check if the
connection is successful or not and if
successful display
connection
successful
next
also
add if the connection is not successful
we should always have an error message
connection
field
next what we need to do is we need to
mysql i
select
underscore
bb
and inside this
we need to mention the name of our
database which is
let's just go back and recheck
photography
because the name is
very important if you
mess with the name the entire code goes
to win
now
let me create some variables which will
fetch
the data
from the form
in order to send them to the database
so
let's keep the same names
so that we don't
create any confusion
email and of course
number
post
so now that we have our variables we
need to run
a
query
so
since we are fetching the data from the
form and inserting it into a table we
need to run a query for insert
into the name of the table that is users
and then
name
email
number
followed by the values that
we'll be
giving them
so
notice this is the name of the
fields that you've given in your table
and
this
these values are these variables that
we've just created
so
inside it
name
second would be
email
and third would be
number
i think the query is done
now
to check if
it works
we will run another query
and i am going to add a header file here
because once you click on submit button
let me just go back
so if you click on submit button here
the page will redirect
to a different page which will just
display connection successful we don't
need that we need to stay on this page
itself so in order to do that
i am writing this header file
with the location
of
index.php
enter
and
i think we are done here
now
let's go back
and
add some details mac
mac add to it
simply
learn learn.com
number would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine
zero
click on submit
go back to your database
click on browse
and if the connection would be
successful you can see the
data here
and we can mac
email and number
that's great
so
now let's move on to the final section
of the website
so
how do we make this categories
navbar work
well it's pretty simple we just need to
redirect to a section
of a web page whenever clicked a button
so when we click on nature we need
a web page to be redirected to this
section so
let's just go back to our code and what
we're going to be doing is we will
create
links
just a second
for every section of our webpage so
let's go back to the first section that
is
nature
and here
right
give it an id
so the id for this section
would be
nature
close the tag
cut
and
paste it here so as you can see
this id
this section of our web page is enclosed
in this id so now with this a tag we can
refer
our this section of the webpage
to any button
similarly
we will add
another id here
so the id would be
architecture of course
make sure the spellings are correct
put it after the section
now
go back a id
this would be
travel
okay
just a second
cut it
paste it here
again
i'm going to do is instead of writing it
again and again
i'll just copy it from here
paste it
since this is
contact us
let
[Music]
and the section
right
and
this will be
of course
about
yes
good now what we need to do is we need
to refer these sections with the
respective ids to the buttons
go back to the navbar code on your
webpage
so here is a navbar code
so inside it you can see after every
button there's a reference you just need
to
add the name of your id
do not remove this
and
architecture
travel
contact
and
about
let's go back
refresh
click on categories
okay
what happened here okay no
nature
yep
travel
yep
contact
about so everything works perfectly now
so while we're added let me just okay
let me first show you
um rob
start dot com
one two three four five five five five
five
click on submit
so as you can see whenever you click on
submit
it redirects you to the front of the
webpage
i don't want that
yeah the database is working so
just go back
to the
about.php and here we added the header
location index.php so it is redirecting
the
code to the
start of the web page
what we need to do is we need to
redirect it to a particular section that
is contact so just add
contact in front of it
save
go back
down
tony
tony
[Music]
stark
industries.com
one two three seven seven seven seven
seven seven
click on submit
and as you can see after you click on
submit the page does not go back to the
starting it just stays here while the
data has been submitted
to our database
now that we have completed our website a
quick question for you guys
if you were asked to create a website
based on your interest what would the
website be about
let us know in the comment section below
now let me show you a glimpse of the
website we'll be creating which is
called techbad.com
but you can obviously create a website
for the product of your choice
so let me just go to the browser
type in
localhost website and this is the
website that we'll be creating this is a
very basic website for e-commerce
services but as you can see we have
displayed the top products on the front
page of a website and here from the drop
down menu you can see laptops
and phones
so without wasting much time let's get
started
now before we begin let me tell you that
we'll be using visual studio code as the
ide our code editor and
zam as the web server solutions package
which will be hosting a local server
server for the website
now another thing that we need to do
before beginning
is we need to go to a
browser and type in
bootstrap
download
go to this website
and from here
download the bootstrap
file this will be a compressed file you
can download it from here and i'll tell
you later what we're going to do with it
now let's go and set up a coding
environment
so let me just close this
go to c
exam folder
locate htdocs folder in it and
create
any name for your project
i'll be writing website
and inside this website what you're
going to do is
go to your downloads
now this bootstrap folder that we just
downloaded we are going to extract it
inside
that
website folder
so
let's just go back
so
we need them outside
delete this
so as you can see we have got a css and
js folder and we will be using this in a
website
now let us begin
our code
so right click
open with code
now this is our visual studio code and
as you can see
our website folder is visible here and
from here
we can create a new file
so our first file would be
index dot php
now let's start a code
type in exclamation mark
and hit enter and you can see
this block of code
will be visible here
now we need to add a few things
well not a few quite a lot
first would be
title
the title would be
well
since my website is take by i'm going to
keep the title as take by
next what we're going to do is we are
going to add
some links
to this index.php
so these are the links for the css files
present inside this folder that we just
downloaded from bootstrap
and we'll be linking some of the files
from this folder onto
our website so that the website looks
good yeah
now the reference would be
css this is the folder and
the file is bootstrap
dot
m i n dot css
so this is the first file that we're
going to be linking
next
let's add
a script here
so this is a pretty popular script
and you can find it on the internet
easily
checks
well yeah
this ends a script here
let me just recheck if i typed
it correctly
yeah seems fine
now moving on
we are going to be adding another script
that would be
javascript
and
it will include boots
jquery
sorry bootstrap
i'm just going to find it
bootstrap.man.js
here this ends the second script
now
let us just
end
this title
and move on to the
body part of the
code
now
what do we need to produce or create
first
now the first thing that we need is a
navigation bar
so
to create a navigation bar i'll give you
a pretty easy way to do that instead of
writing a hefty big code you need to go
to your browser
since we are using bootstrap why not
take the best out of it
now type in bootstrap
navbar
go to this link navbar bootstrap
and as you can see this bootstrap
this navbar can
be accessed using this code
just copy it go back and paste it in
your body
now we'll be making a few changes to a
navigation bar according to our
e-commerce website but before that we
need to check if this navigation bar is
visible correctly on the web page now to
do that
first
let's open our xampp control panel
start our apache server
and go to a browser
now to see the result of your code to
see if this code that you've just
written
is
how does it look on a web page we need
to type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder that you created for
your project since the name of my folder
is website i've written website here
click on enter
and well our navigation bar looks a bit
weird
there's no designing to it now let me go
back to
the code and see what i did wrong
well
yeah we don't need this bootstrap
reboot.min.css instead
we need
just
bootstrap.min.css
let's
save it go back and reload
well our navigation bar is visible
let's go back to the code
and start making some of our changes
the first change that i'm going to be
making is i will change the
color theme of this navigation bar
and
yeah looks much better
now let me remove
some things
first
let's change the name to
textby.com
well
second
let us let it be home
so this is the drop down i will be
changing it to
products
the first product is
laptop
the second one
phones
we don't need this here
and
let me put the divider
in between
we don't need this
disabled part
either
and
neither do we need the search form
now i want to make a few changes to the
navigation bar
so this navigation bar seems a little
thin
let me add
just a little bit of
breadth to it
yep
looks good
and as you can see
laptops phones and this dividing line
now what we need to do create a front
page that is the top featured content
on the front way that will be visible on
our ecommerce website so to do that
create a div class
let us name it
and
this will be a column
div inside this
another div class
this will be for the row
and
now
just a second
yes
this will also need a class since we
want our
text
in the center of the page
and
top products
okay
let me
just add some spaces
well
before adding those images and the
products onto a page we need to prepare
a little bit more so before that let us
just save this piece of code and
see how does it look so it displays top
products in the center of the page
looks great
now
what we need to do before we can display
the products on
this page is we need to create a
database in where we are going to store
all the information regarding our
products
and we will fetch that data from the
database and display it on our website
now to create the database just go back
to the xampp control panel and start the
mysql server too
now
here
type in localhost
php
myadmin
and you can see you
are now redirected to the php my admin
control panel
where you can create
different databases
so as you can see i've already created a
database named tech by
under which i have got
another table that is products
with some data here
now
i'll show you how to create a database
from scratch
now to do that we need to go to this new
part
now since we already have a text by
database let us name it something
different
e-commerce
and
create
now
we have created a database named
e-commerce and inside the e-commerce
what we need to do is we need to create
a table
let us create the table and name it
products
now our table with will mainly consist
of around
six or seven
columns and
let us keep it seven
the first would be id of course and it
will be auto incremented
the second
title of the product
which will be a variable character
2 55
price of the product
since
prices can be
in decimal
let us keep this decimal
and
the values would be 10 comma 2
next is brand name
this is variable character
image now this
column here will
contain the location of the image on our
server or on a system since our system
is the local server
so
this will also be a variable character
255
next would be description
this will be a text since a description
can be long
and
last could be featured
all right
let us save this table
and we have a products table here
in our new database that is e-commerce
now we need some images for this
image file for our products
now i've already downloaded some images
let me just
copy them
now go back to a c drive zam
what we are going to do is we are going
back to our website folder
and
we will be creating a new folder inside
the website folder
and let us name it images
and paste your
images here
let me go back to
this visual studio code and as you can
see
our images are visible here
we'll be using them very soon
let us go back to
this
and let me add an entry here so we'll be
working
with one product and once you understand
the concept you can add many more
products later on
so
the title would be
google
pixel 5
the price
65000
brand name goes google
image
now to add the path of your image
what you need to do is you need to go
back
here
images now the path would be inside
website
and inside images folder so
website
images
and then followed by the name of the
image since the name for my
google phone is g pixel
i'll be writing
g
pixel dot png
make sure you do not make a mistake by
writing a name
and in the description
well i've copied some description from
the internet i will be posting
the same here
google pixel 5 5g hdb ram 128 gb
space now
inside the featured part
we'll be numbering it one and click on
go
so go back to browse
and you can see
your field that you just created visible
here
so now that we have the entry
for our image for our product that is
google pixel 5 phone in our database let
us go back to the code to see how to
retrieve this
information from this database into a
code and display it on our screen
let's go back to our code
and in our code
let's go back to the
top
and here
we are going to be creating a
php
script
and inside that script
i will be
accessing the database
now
let us create a connection to the
database using mysql
connect
and inside this what we're going to do
is we will be writing the name of
loop the server since the server is
localhost
and then
this
next would be root
now
again
mysqli
now here select
db
database and inside this
we'll be selecting a database from
the my admin panel
so what we need to do is we need to
write the variable name followed by the
name of the database that we need
information from so our the name of our
database
was
e-commerce
yep
so
e-commerce
so here we have created a connection
with the database now
let us create another file sql so
for this this variable will be accessing
all the information stored in our table
products
so
we'll be writing some
sql commands
select star that is all the details from
name of our table
products let me just recheck
products yep
and
where
featured is equals to one
so remember that
while
creating a
entry we put this featured value as one
so
this part of the code is done now
let us go back down
where we stopped last
and
write
our
php
script
so
here
what we are going to do is we will be
creating a while loop
now inside while loop
we will create another
variable as products
which will be equals to
my sqli
and this function is used to fetch
the data from the database
and
feature
well there's something that we missed
we did not create the variable featured
here and
well it would have given an error
so
what featured would do is featured would
use the connection to query
the
sql command
now
go back
here
what this while loop will be doing is
this while loop
will be fetching
the data
from our table under the category of
featured number one
so
next what we're going to do is next we
will create another
div class
which would be
inside this h4
another
php
script
is equals to product
now
inside this
we are since this will be the title we
will be displaying the title from here
so what we need to do is we need to add
the title
and
close the
php script here
next
we need to display the image
so
here in this image src we don't need to
write the path of the image since we
have already entered that into the
database what we need to do is we need
to specify
the path
from where we need to fetch the image
from the database so
it's pretty simple
again
the same thing
product and as you
would have guessed it
it will
be
image was it image or images
let me just recheck
it was image
close this close the file
and
here we have retrieved our image now
protect
inside this product what we are going to
get is
the price
title so that if one would hover over
here it will display the title of the
product
and
that's it
we need to close it
set
okay so
yeah
looks good
next
we will display
the price of the product
to do that
we will create a class
let us name it
price
close it
rupees
we're doing it again
product
and
here
we what we need to do is we need to get
the
price and close this
similarly
whatever details that we need to display
here from the database we are going to
be accessing them
through
this script
with changing the name of the column
that we need to access
so
now that we have all this let us
also
create a reference page
and
i'll be creating another file
details.php which will display the
details of the product
but
before that let me create a button
type
button class
button success
now the name of the button would be more
and
well
this ends here
also what we need to do is we need to
let me
just see what we need to do is we need
to
end this
while loop
and while
here
and
just
close it
so
this
div
and this div
everything's good
save
let's go back
and see if it's working
and
voila
we have our first product
displayed here
on the front page of our ecommerce
website google pixel 5 the phone the
more button does not work yet
but we'll be working on it but
it feels good doesn't it
now let us go back to the code
and see
how to create this details.php file
first
details.php and inside this file what
we're going to do is we are going to
just copy paste some part of the code
here
and
also this part of the code
okay
and
we don't need it
now we need
one or two more things to be displayed
here so
just copy this
paste it
and paste it again let's go back to
[Music]
our localhost and what we need to
display here is
so we have already displayed the title
the price
and the image
so the things that we're left with is
the description
and the brand name
so let's go back
price is already here
just add description
and
brand name
was it brand
name yep brand name
description
it's good
change
class name here
okay
so
what we're going to do is we will be
refreshing this page and clicking on
more
and
well yes good the details of our product
are visible here
now let's go back and
make a little changes
so the first change would be
this so
this would be
product
details
and
save
click
and there's still
a big gap
yes looks better
now
let me just
you can add some bold or
italics
or whatever you like
in this code
um what did i do
so i've added bold in the title
let's see if it works
i'm not sure if it does
okay since it's already a heading
my bad
let me
add it here
okay
save it so this is the price
and yes price is in bold now so you can
make a few changes so look make
your description look better
and let us go back to the main page and
what we're going to do is we are going
to
create two new files for this laptops
and phones to display them separately
when we click on any drop down menu
since they don't work yet
let me show you an example to create a
file for this product laptops
and you can create
the rest yourself so
first thing that we need to do is we
need to go back to this database
into a table
and
create another entry
so the title would be
asus ro
laptop
price would be
1 lakh 20 000 brand name asus
image so the image is website
images
and the name of the image is
prog asus
dot png
wrote asus dot tmg
[Music]
i've copied some description for the
from the internet
and
now the one thing that you need to
notice is we are going to be
keeping this featured part as
2 instead of 1
and go back to browse and you can see
the detail that we just created with the
feature number 2. so now go back to our
code and create another file let us name
it
laptops dot php
let me just see
yep
i have
so
yeah i may have skipped this part so in
the drop down menu when we created a
navigation bar here it was written
this
so we need to replace this reference
with the name of the
php file that we just created that is
product dash laptops dot php so pro
duct dash laptops dot php
and inside this
first thing that we need to do is copy
this code paste it here
now here change it to
two
and drop down
top products everything looks
fine
save it
since the feature number will be 2
let us go back
refresh
click on laptops
and here you can see the asus rogue
laptop visible
now let me
add another product on our feature page
that is a front page to show you how do
we display more than one product with
the same code so
go back to this database and create
another entry
let's say
hp
laptop
price would be
80 000
okay i think i just
created an entry
let me delete it
go back
hp laptop
price
80 000
name hp
image
website
images
name of the image
that is hp underscore
laptop.png
hp underscore laptop.png
and the description which i have copied
from the internet
and in this feature we are going to be
writing one
since we are displaying this on the
front page
of our website
go back to browse here are the details
now
let's get back
we don't need to change anything just
save it
go back
and refresh
and
as you can see we have our hp laptop
visible here and similarly
we can just re add products into a
database and this single piece of code
is enough to display them all on a web
page
so guys these are some of the basics of
an e-commerce website you can add more
products choices more detailed
descriptions and add more designing
using css bootstrap cards
and
buy sell
sections on your website
just play along with the code and start
making your own web pages with companies
generating enormous volumes of data
every minute it has become really
important to make sense of this data and
draw business insights
and very often this data is stored
inside relational databases in the form
of rows and columns
sql or sql is the language to
communicate with databases
the history of sql dates back to 1970
when edgar kurd a computer scientist
working for ibm wrote a paper that
described a new system of organizing
data in databases
sql is used to create maintain
manipulate and retrieve vast volumes of
data present in relational databases
such as mysql microsoft sql server
oracle db and ibm db2
sql is in high demand because so many
companies use it that includes big
giants such as amazon google oracle and
microsoft as well as startups the
popularity of sql has grown over the
years and is one of the most sought
after skills by employers
sql is everywhere it plays a critical
role in almost every kind of job whether
you are a software developer data
analyst marketing analyst product
manager or a data scientist sql will
make your life easier and save your time
sql still remains the top language for
data work it is easy to learn and does
not require any prior coding knowledge
using sql commands you can unlock the
power of business intelligence tools
like tableau and answer any questions
related to the data it can also
integrate with scripting languages such
as python and r
according to glassdoor the average
salary of a sql developer is 88 912
dollars per annum in the united states
that's a lot of money
so what's stopping you from learning sql
join us in our full course journey to
learn the basics and advanced concepts
of sql that will help you solve business
problems and make critical decisions
what is a database so according to
oracle a database is an organized
collection of structured information or
data that is typically stored
electronically in a computer system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data
relational databases store data in the
form of tables that can be easily
retrieved managed and updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information now talking
about some of the popular databases
we have mysql database we also have
oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database
next we have microsoft sql server next
we have apache casendra which is a free
and open source nosql database and
finally we have postgresql now
let's learn
what is sql so sql is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
sql was initially developed by ibm
most databases use structured query
language or sql for writing and querying
data sql commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this
let's look at what a table is
so this is how a table in a database
looks like
so here you can see
the name of the table is players
on the top you can see the column names
so we have the player id the player name
the country to which the player belongs
to and we also have the goals scored by
each of the players
so these are also known as fields in a
database
here each row
represents a record or a tuple
so if you have the player id which is
103 here the name of the player is
daniel
he is from england and the number of
goals here score is 7. so you can use
sql commands to query update insert
records and do a lot of other tasks
now we'll see what the features of sql
are
sql lets you access any information
stored in a relational database
with sql queries data is extracted from
the database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from oracle ibm to microsoft
and it doesn't require much coding to
manage databases
now we will see applications of sql
sql is used to create a database define
its structure implement it and lets you
perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data and extracting data
in a database
sql is extensively used as a
client-server language to connect the
front-end with the back-end thus
supporting the client server
architecture
sql when deployed as data control
language dcl
helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
in this session we will learn who is a
sql developer and what are the
responsibilities in a company then we
will focus on the skills required to
become a successful sql developer we
will see the expected average salary in
both us and india we will also discuss
how to become a sql developer and look
at the top companies hiring for sql
developers so hey everyone i am abhishah
rahuja from simplylearn and welcome to
this video on how to become a sql
developer but before we begin if you
love watching tech videos subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
when going through some of the popular
job boards online you would easily see
sql developer is one of the most
demanding jobs seek by companies
as we all know today companies collect
vast volumes of data and store it in
their own databases they want
professionals with a good understanding
of data who can keep it safe and secure
so first we will understand who is a sql
developer
sql developer is a person who is
accountable in creating and managing
huge data assets of a company
in other terms sql developer is a person
who can develop sql databases as well as
write and test code
let's understand this with the help of
an example
let's say we want to search a particular
product on amazon website and amazon has
stored all its data about products in a
database now we will write the product
name in the search bar and when we click
on the search button it will run a sql
query that fetches all the information
about the product and displays us on the
website so this is the basic task done
by a sql developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of a sql developer
all databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a sql developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses that is
called database modeling
after the database is created and
deployed it's the sql developer who is
responsible for fixing the general
issues of the database
sql developer should be well-versed with
structured query language to create
optimized sql queries and refines the
existing ones to extract information
from the database
sql developers run several diagnostic
tests to keep a check on the server and
the database in order to understand how
to organize companies data sql
developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business and sql developer also
gathers client requirements and
identifies the features that the
database owners want
as data is an asset to a company sql
developers backup and restore data for
their clients
they also perform tasks like data
management and data migration that is if
a company has stored all its data on a
local storage and now it wants its data
to be stored in a cloud storage so the
safe transmission of the data from local
storage to cloud storage is known as
data migration and that is done by the
sql developers
after knowing the responsibilities now
should look for skill set required to be
a good sql developer
one should have a good knowledge of sql
commands functions joins and procedures
let's have a look at few commands such
as create drop alter and truncate these
commands come under data definition
language we also have insert update and
delete commands these commands come
under data manipulation language we have
grant and devop commands these commands
come under data control language we also
have commit rollback and save point
commands these come under transaction
control language these are the basic
commands a sql developer should be
familiar with
and a sql developer may have a little
command on any one programming language
you don't have to be expert in
programming all you need is how to
interface between application and your
database for example you are using mysql
and your web application is based on php
then you should know how to connect your
application to the database and how to
issue queries
how to fetch results and then how to
display it to the users
one should have a good understanding of
various database management systems such
as mysql microsoft access oracle postgre
sql dbase foxpro
sqlite ibm db2 libreoffice base mariadb
and microsoft sql server
one should know integration of databases
with data visualization software such as
power bi and tableau which helps
businesses to make better decisions and
give you an add-on as a sql developer
one should develop critical thinking and
problem solving skills to create
optimized queries
now we'll see how a sql developer is
compensated in both united states and
india
in the united states sql developers draw
an average salary of dollar 72
282 per annum
in india the average salary of a sql
developer is rupees 4 lakh 49532
now we'll see how person can become a
good sql developer for that
one should have a good command on
structured query language and know how
to interact with database management
system and can issue queries to get the
desired result
earning industry recognized sql
developer certifications such as
microsoft certified professional
developer mcpd or oracle pl sql
developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam
and it's important to accumulate as much
practical experience as possible start
by designing creating and querying small
databases connected with your hobbies
and interests for example your favorite
music videos or your personal finances
this will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio which will be highly
beneficial when you start applying for
your first full-time position
now we will see some major companies
recruiting sql developers first we have
the multinational financial services
corporation american express followed by
the multinational professional services
network ernst and young we also have the
messaging company whatsapp then we have
the e-commerce giant amazon as well as
the technology and computer solutions
company dell finally in a list of
companies we have the multinational
technology company google there are
mainly four types of sql commands
so first we have data definition
language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database
we have create alter drop and truncate
as ddl commands
next
we have data manipulation language or
dml
so dml commands are used to modify your
database it is responsible for all forms
of changes in the database dml commands
are not auto committed which means it
can't permanently save all the changes
in the database
we have select
update
delete and insert as dml commands now
select command is also referred to as
dql or data query language third we have
data control language or dcl
so dcl commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these dcl commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have grant and rework which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or tcl
so tcl commands allow the user to manage
database transactions
commit and roll back our example of tcl
now let's see the basic sql command
structure
so first
we have the select statement
so here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next
we have the where clause to filter out
our table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by clause that
takes various column names so you can
write group by column 1 column 2 and so
on next we have the having clause to
filter out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in sql
so we have
exact numeric which has integer small
end bit and decimal
then we have
approximate numeric
which are float and real
then we have some date and time data
type such as date time time stamp and
others
then we have string data type which
includes car this varchar and text
finally we have binary data types
and binary data types have binary
var binary and image
now let's see some of the various
operators that are present in sql
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than now let me take
you to my mysql workbench where we will
learn to write some of the important sql
commands use different statements
functions data types and operators that
we just learned now let me now go ahead
and open my mysql workbench so in the
search bar i'll search for
my sql workbench you can see i'm using
the 8.0 version
i'll click on it and
here it says welcome to mysql workbench
and below under connections you can see
i have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the localhost and the port
number let me click on it
you can see the service the username is
root and i'll enter my password
and hit ok
now this will open the sql editor so
this is how the mysql workbench looks
like
here
we learn some of the basic sql commands
so first let me show you the databases
that are already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to autocomplete i'll use
a semicolon
i'll select this and here on the top you
can see the execute button so if i run
this
below you can see the output
it says
show databases seven rows are returned
which means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right
now
let's say in
see the tables that are present inside
this database called world
so i'll use the command use world which
is the database name
now let me run it so currently i'm using
the world database
so to display the tables that are
present in the world database i can use
the show command
and write show tables
give a semicolon
and i'll hit ctrl enter this time to run
it
all right so you can see the tables that
are present inside this
world database so we have three tables
in total city country and country
language
now
if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command
so i'll write select star which
basically means i want to display all
the columns so star here means to
display all the columns
then i'll write my
from
the table name that is
city
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if i hit ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it says
thousand rows were returned which means
there were total thousand records
present inside the city table
so here you can see there's an id column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right
similarly you can check the structure of
the table by using the describe command
so i'll write describe and then
i'll give the
table name that is city now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have id name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
id is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key
and these are some extra information now
let's learn how to create a table in
mysql so i'll use the
create table command for this and before
that
let me create a database
and i'll name it as sql intro so the
command is create
database
and i'll give my database name that is
sql underscore intro
let me give a semicolon and hit ctrl
enter
so you can see i have created a new
database
now
if i run this command that is show
databases
you can see this
newly created database that is sql intro
if i scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
sql intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the sql
intro database
so i'll use the command create
table
and then
i'll give my
table name that is going to be employee
underscore details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so i'll use
varchar
and i'll give a value of 25
so it can hold only 25 characters
okay
next
i also want the age of the employee
now age is always an integer
so i'll give int
okay
then
we can have the gender of the employee
so gender can be represented as f or m f
for female and m for male so i'm
using the car data type or character
data type and i'll give the value as one
then let's have the
date of join
or doj
and this is going to be of data type
date
all right
next
we'll have the city name that is the
city to which the employee belongs to
so again this is going to be varchar
15
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary will keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well
now i will give a semicolon
all right so let me just quickly run
through it so first
i wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then
we gave the column names such as name
age
this gender
date of join city and salary
for each of the columns we also gave the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay
so here you can see we have successfully
created our first table
now
you can use the
describe command to see the structure of
the table
i'll write describe emp underscore
details
if i run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if
the table can accept null values or not
and these are basically
empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command
so on a notepad i have already
written my insert statement so let me
just copy it and then i'll explain it
one by one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command
followed by
the table name that is emp details
then this is the syntax using values i
have passed in
all the records
so first we have jimmy which is the name
of the employee then we have 35 it
basically represents the age
then m means the gender or the sex
then we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
shane
you can see the age another information
then we have
mary this duane sarah and amy
all right
so let me go ahead and
run this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so i'm using
select star from emp underscore details
if i run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has
so we have the name column the each
column the state of join city salary
and these are the values that you can
see here
moving ahead now let's say you want to
see the unique city names present in the
table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have chicago seattle boston austin
this new york and there's seattle
repeated again so i only want to print
the unique values
so for that i can write my select
statement as select
distinct then i'll give my column name
which is city from
my table name that is emp details
if i run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have chicago
seattle which was repeated twice is just
been shown once then we have boston
austin and new york now let's see how
you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in sql
so suppose you want to count the number
of employees in the table for in that
case you can use the count function in
the select statement so let me show you
how to do that
so i'll write
select i'll use my function name that is
count
now since i want to know the
total number of employees i am going to
use their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if i run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have
six employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all
so what sql provides is something called
as an alias name so you can give an
alias to the resultant output so here i
can write select count of name
and use an alias as
as
i can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our alias name
now suppose you want to get the total
sum of salaries you can use another
aggregate function called sum
so i'll write my select statement
and this time instead of count i'm going
to write sum
and since i want to find the sum of
salaries
so inside the bracket i'll give my
salary column
from
my table name that is employee details
if i run this
this will result in the total sum of
salaries
so basically it adds up
all the salaries that were present in
the salary column
now let's say you want to find the
average salary so instead of sum you can
write the average function which is avg
so this will give you the average salary
from the column salary so you can see it
here this says average salary now if you
want you can give an alias name to this
as well now you can select specific
columns from the table by using the
column names in the select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like
you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to
see only specific columns you can
mention those column names in the select
statement
so let's say i want to select
just the name
age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name agent city
column
from the table if i run it there you go
it has given only three columns to me
now sql has a where clause to filter
rows based on a particular condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where clause now where clause comes
after
you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees
with age greater than 30 in this case
you can use a where clause so let me
show you how to do it
i'll write select
star from
my table name that is
employee
details
and after this i'll use my where clause
so i'll write where
age
greater than
30.
if i run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30.
so we have four employees whose age is
greater than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table
you can also use a where clause here
so i'll write
select
let's say i want only the name the
gender which is
sex here
comma city
from my table that is employee details
where
i'll give my column name that is sex is
equal to
since i want only the female employees
i'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here
our employee table has three female
employees
now suppose you want to find the details
of the employees who belong to chicago
or austin in this case you can use the
or operator
now the or operator in sql displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by or is true
so let me show you what i mean
so since i want the employees who are
from chicago and austin
i can use
an or operator so i'll write select star
from
emp details which is my table name
then i'll give my where clause where
city
equal to
i'll give my
city name as cicago
and then i'm going to use the or
operator or
city
equal to
i'll write austin
i'll give a semicolon and let me run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city chicago and
austin
now there is another way to write the
same sql query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so
let me just copy this and instead of
using the or operator
this time i'm going to use the in
operator
so i'll delete this
after the where clause i'm going to
write where city
and use the in operator
inside bracket
i'll give my city names as chicago
and i want
austin so i'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
austin so this query is exactly the same
that we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have jimmy and duane who are from
chicago and austin respectively
now sql provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
now suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of jan 2000 and
31st of december 2010
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write select star from
emp details
where
my date of join that is doj
between
i'll give my two date values that is
first of
jan
2000
and
i'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of december 2010.
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output
if i run it
we have two employees who had joined
between
2000 and 2010 so we have jimmy and mary
here who had joined in 2005 and 2009
respectively
all right
now in where clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example
i'll write select
star from
employee details table
where
i want the age to be greater than 30
and i want
sex to be
male
all right so here you can see i have
specified two conditions so if both the
conditions are true only then it will
result in an output
if i run it
you can see there are
two employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30.
now let's talk about the group by
statement in sql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the result set
into one or more columns
let's say
we want to find the total salary of
employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause so i'll write select
let's say sex
comma
i want to find the total sum of salary
as
i'll give an alias name let's say total
salary
from
my table name that is employee details
next i am going to group it by sex
okay
let me run it
there you go
so we have two genders male and female
and here you can see the total salary so
what this sql statement did was first it
grouped all the employees based on the
gender and then it found the total
salary
now sql provides the order by keyword to
sort the result set in ascending or
descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default
to sort the records in descending order
you can use the desc keyword
so let's say i want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so i'll write select
star from
emp underscore
details
and i'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of the salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement so suppose i write select
and
do an addition operation let's say 10
plus 20
and i'll given alias name as addition
if i run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30.
similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get -10
now there are some basic inbuilt
functions
there are a lot of inbuilt functions in
sql but here i'll show you a few suppose
you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function
so i'll write select and then use the
length function i'll hit tab to auto
complete let's say i want to find the
length of
country india
and i'll give an alias as total
length
if i run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are 5 letters
in india there's another function called
repeat so let me show you how repeat
works
so i'll write select
repeat
let's say i want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
i'll put it in single quotes because it
is a
text character
and i want to repeat this character for
10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count it
all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so i'll write select
and use the function called upper
let's say i want to convert
my string that is india to uppercase
i am not giving in any alias name
if i run this
see my input was
capital i and everything else was in
small letter
in the output you can see it has
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something
lowercase you can use the lower function
let's say
this time everything is in
uppercase if i run it
it converts india to lower case
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there's a function called
cur which stands for current
and this is the function i'm talking
about which is current date
if i run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of jan 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use
the day function let's say i'll use day
and i want to find the day from my
current date
if i run this
you get 28 which is today's
day now similarly you can also
display the current date and time
so for that you can use a function that
is called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right
and this brings us to the end of our
demo session
so let me just scroll through whatever
we have learned so first
i showed you how you can see the
databases present in mysql then we used
one of the databases and checked the
tables in it then we created another
database called sql intro for our demo
purpose
we used that database and then
we created this table called employee
details with
column names like name integer the sex
date of join city and salary
i showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted
records for six employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we saw how you can use the select
statement and display all the columns
present in the table
we learned how you can
display the unique city names
we learnt how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learnt how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learned how to use where clause
then we used
an or operator we learnt about
inoperator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally
we learnt about group by order by and
some basic
sql operations
now it's time to explore some string
functions in
mysql
so i have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case
so i can write select
the function i'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say
i'll write india
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say upper case
i'll give a semicolon
and let's run it
there you go so my input was in sentence
case and using the upper function we
have converted everything into uppercase
similarly let me just copy this
and
i'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lowercase you can use the lower function
and run this you can see the result
everything is in
lower case now of course i need to
change the alias name to lowercase
now instead of using
lower as the function there is another
function that mysql provides which is
called the
l case
so i'll just edit this and write l case
and let's see
i'll write
india in
uppercase
let's run it it returns me the same
result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the
length of a string you can use the
character length function
i'll write select
use the function character length
and i'm again going to pass in my
string as india as
let's say total length
let's run it this time i am going to hit
ctrl enter to run my sql command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because india has 5 characters in
it
now these functions you can also apply
on a table
now let me show you how to do it let's
say we already have the students table
and you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
s2 underscore name
and you can give the same alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is students
if i run this
you can see the output
it has given me
total 20 rows of information
this is not readable actually let me
also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
i'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so joseph has six
characters niles has six vipul has five
anubhav has seven
similarly if you see akshay has six
tanis has seven raghav has six
comments has seven rabada has six
so on and so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
car length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or car length
now there's another very interesting
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more expressions
together
let's say i'll write select
use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and i'm going to pass in
my
string values let's say india
is
in
asia
let's run this and see our result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable i will give
a space in between so that
you can read it clearly
now this is much more readable india is
in asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's see merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
i'm going to use the same students table
let's say i want to return the student
id
followed by the student name
and then
i am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and i can give an alias as let's say
name underscore age
from
my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here the result is very
clear
we have the student id the student name
and the
concatenated column that we created
which was name underscore each where we
have the
student name
with a space followed by the age of the
student
if you scroll down you can see the rest
of the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function works
in mysql
so the mysql reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose i write select
reverse
i'll use the same string again let's say
i have
india
let's run it
you will see all the characters printed
in reverse order again you can perform
the same operation on
a table as well let's see i'll write
select
reverse
and i'll pass in the column as student
name
from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been
printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string
within a new substring
so let me show you what i mean
i'll write select
replace
i'll pass in my input string which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect
i am purposely writing this so that i
can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
orange is a fruit
all right
now
mysql also provides some trim functions
you can use the
left trim right trim and adjust the trim
function
so let me show you how this
left trim works
left trim
or l trim removes the leading space
characters from a string passed as an
argument
so see i write select
i'll use the left trim function which is
l trim
and then i'm going to purposely give a
few species
in the beginning of the string i'll give
a word let's say india and then i'll
give some space after the
bird india
and see
how the
l trim works if i run this
it gives me india which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the
length of my string
so i'll use my
length function here
and
within this function i am going to
find the length of my string which has
india along with some
leading and trailing spaces i'll paste
this here
give a semicolon and i'll run it
okay
so the entire string is
17
characters long or the length of the
string is 17.
now say i use l trim on my same string
what it returns me is india
and if i
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see
how many spaces were deleted from the
left of the string you can see here
now it says 17
and
i'm going to use l trim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so 17 minus
5 is
12 which is correct similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these pieces
when you use left trim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace l trim with
r trim which stands for right trim
and see the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here
if i just write trim and i'll
run it
it gives me 5
because india is total 5 characters long
and it has deleted all the leading and
the trailing spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in mysql the position function returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substring in a string
so if the substring is not found with
the original string the function will
return
so let's say i'll write select
position
i want to
find
where
fruit is in my string that is
orange
is
a
fruit
i'll give an alias as neem
the sum error here
it should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place
or at the 13th position we have the word
fruit in our string which is orange is a
fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ascii
so the ascii function returns the ascii
value for a specific character
let's say i write select
ascii
of
the letter small a
if i run this
it will give me the ascii value which is
97
let's say you want to find the ascii
value
of
4
let's see the result
it gives me
52
all right
in this session we are going to learn
two important sql statements or clauses
that are widely used that is grouped by
and having
first we will understand the basics of
group by and having and then
jump into mysql workbench to implement
these statements so let's begin first
what is group by in sql
so the group by statement or clause
groups records into summary rows and
returns one record for each group it
groups the rows with the same group by
item expressions and computes aggregate
functions for the resulting group
a group by clause is a part of select
expression
in each group no two rows have the same
value for the grouping column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by
so first we have the select statement
and then followed by the column names
that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition
and next we have the group by clause
and here we include the column names
finally we have the order by and the
column names
now here is an example of the group by
clause
so we want to find the average salary of
employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee id
the employee name
the age of the employee we have the
gender
the date on which the employer joined
the company then we have the department
to which each of these employees belong
to we have the city to which the
employees belong to and then we have the
salary in dollars
so actually we'll be using this
employees table on mysql workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your
sql query with group by clause would
look like so we have selected department
and then we are using an aggregate
function that is avg which is average
and
we have chosen the salary column and
here we have given an alias name which
is average underscore salary which
appears in the output you can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see
we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department
now let me take you to my mysql
workbench where we will implement group
by and solve specific problems
okay so i am on my mysql workbench so
let me make my connection first
i'll enter the password
so this will open my sql editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that i have
so i'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here
i'm going to use my
sql underscore intro database so i'll
write
use
sql underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database i'll run it
all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in sql
underscore intro database
if i write show tables you can see the
list of
tables that are already present in this
database to do our demo and understand
group by as well as having let me first
create an employee table
so i'll write create table
employees
next
i'll give my column name as employee
underscore id which is
the id for each employee
i'll give my data type as integer and
i'll assign
employee id as my primary key
next i'll give
employee underscore
name
and my data type would be
varchar
i'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then i have
my gender column
i'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1.
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
department column as well this is going
to be of
varchar
and 20 will be the size
next we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally
we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees
okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
i'll write describe employees
you can see
the structure of the table so far
all right now it's time for us to insert
a few records
into this employees table so i'll write
insert
into
employees
and i'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my emp notepad and you can
see i have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if all
the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information
or the records that are present in our
employees table
i'll write select star from employees if
i run it you can see here
i have my employee id the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
instead 20 records
now
let me run a few sql commands to check
how the structure of our table is
let's say i want to see the distant
cities that are present in our table
so i'll write select distinct city from
employees
if i run this
you see here there are total
eight different cities present in our
employees table so we have
chicago the shuttle boston we have new
york miami and detroit as well
now let's see
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present so you can use distinct
department
if i run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
name so we have sales marketing product
tech i.t finance and hr
all right
now let me show you
another sql command
now this is to use an aggregate function
so i want to find the
average age of all the employees from
the table
so i can write
select
avg which is the
aggregate function for average
inside that i have passed my
age column from employees if i run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is
33.35
now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
i'll give a comment here i want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
i'll write select
department
comma
i'll write
average of age
from
employees
group by
department
now if i run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left
and on the right you can see the average
age of employees in each of these
departments now you can see here
in the output it says evg of each which
is not readable so i can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
i can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also so you can round the decimal places
so i'll use a round function before the
average function
and
the round function takes two parameters
one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if i run this
there you go you can see here we have
the
average age of all the employees in each
of these departments
all right
now suppose
you want to find the total salary of all
the employees for each department
so
you can write select
department
comma
now i want the total salary so i'll use
the sum function
and i'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
group by
department
let's run this query
you can see here
in the output we have the different
departments
and on the right you can see the total
salary of all the employees in each of
these departments
now here also you can give an alias name
as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the
output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by clause
along with the group by clause
let's say you want to find the total
number of employees in each city and
group it in the order of employee id so
to do this i can use my select query
i'll write select
count of let's say employee
id and i want to
know the city as well
from
employees
group by
city
and next
you can use the order by clause
i'll write order by
count
of
employee id
and i'll write desc which stands for
descending
if i run this query
you can see here
on the left you have the count of
employees
and on the right you can see the
city names so in chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had seattle houston
boston austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee id
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that join the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column
then we can count the employee ids and
group the result by each year
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select
i'm going to extract here from
the date of join column
i'll give an alias as year
next
i'll
count the
employee id
from my table name that is
employees
and
i am going to group it by
year
date of join
i give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
great
you see here in the result we have
the year
that we have extracted from the date of
join column and on the right you can see
the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was
one employee similarly we have in 2009
there were two employees
if you scroll down you have information
of other years as well
now if you want you can
order this as well based on year or
count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so
to show you this operation let me first
create a sales table
so i'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product id
which is going to be
of integer type
then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be
a float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so i'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have
the state in which the item was sold
and state i'll put it as worker and give
the size as 20.
let's run this so that will create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so i've already written
the records in a notepad let me show you
okay so here you can see i have my
sales text file let me just copy these
information
i'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted nine
rows of information
so
let me just
run it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product id column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold
then we have the quantity that was sold
and in which state it was sold so we
have california texas alaska
then we have
another product
id which is one two three
and these are the states in which the
products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement i'll write select star
from
sales
where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose
you want to find the revenue for both
the product ids
one two one and let's say one two three
since we have just two product id's here
so for that you can use the select query
so i'll write select
product id
next
i want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but selling price
multiplied by the quantity
so i'll use the sum function to find the
total revenue
and inside the sum function i'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
my quantity column
i'll give this
an alias name as revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally i'll group it by
product id
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product ids one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated
from these two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that i'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
i'll write create table
let's say the table name is c product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
i'll
give my first column as product id
this will be an integer
and i'll have my second column as
cost price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this
so we have successfully created our
product cost table
now let me
insert a few values into the c product
table so i'll write insert into
c underscore
product
i'll give
my values
for one to one
let's see the
cost price was
270 dollars
for each
and next we have my
product as one two three
and let's say the cost price for product
one two three was
two hundred and fifty
dollars let's insert these two values
okay
next we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the
products
so i'll write select
c dot
product underscore id
comma
i'll write
sum
s dot cell underscore price now here c
and s are alias names
so if i subtract my
cost price from the selling price
that will return the profit that was
generated
i'll multiply this with s dot
quantity close the bracket
i'll give an alias name as
profit
from
sales as s
so here s stands for the sales table i
am going to use
inner join
c underscore
product table
as
the alias name should be c
where
s dot
product underscore id is equal to
c dot
product underscore id
we are using product underscore id
because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
i am going to
group it by
c dot product underscore id
all right
so let me tell you what i have done here
so i'm selecting the product id
next i'm calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and i have multiplied the
quantity column
i'm using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and i am joining on the
column that is product id and have
grouped it by c dot product id
let's run this there you go so here you
can see for product id one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product id one two three we made
a profit of
840
so now that we have learnt group by in
detail let's learn about the having
clause in sql
the having clause in sql operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where clause are kind
of similar but where clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the where
conditions next we have the
group by
finally we have having
and at last we have order by column
names so you can see here we have a
question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees
so you can see the employee table that
we had used in
our
group by clause as well so if you were
to find the cities where there are more
than two employees so this is how your
sql query should look like
so we have
selected
the employee id and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
city
and then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee id should be greater
than two
so if you see the output we have the
different city names and these were the
cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2
all right so let's go to our mysql
workbench and implement how
having works
so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000
you can use the having clause for this
so let me first run my table which is
employees
if i run this you can see
we had inserted 20 rows of information
and
the last column we had was salary so the
question we have is
we want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write
select
department comma
i'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
i'll give an alias name as
evg
underscore salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
group by clause and i want to group it
by each department
and then i am going to write my
having clause so in having clause i'll
use my condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
thousand dollars
let's run it
and see the output
there you go
so here you can see
there were total three departments in
the company that is sales finance in hr
where the average salary is greater than
75 000 dollars
okay
next
let's say you want to find the cities
where the total salary is greater than
200 000
so
this will again be a simple
sql query so i'll write select city
comma
i want to find the total salary so i'll
use the sum function
and i'll pass my column as salary as
i'll give a
alias name as total
from
employees
group by
city and then i am going to use my
having clause
i will pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are chicago
sheetel and houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
i'll write select
department comma
this time since i want to find the
number of employees i'm going to use the
count function
i'll write count star
as
employee underscore count or emp
underscore count which is my alias name
from
employees
next i'll group it by
department
having
i'll give my condition
count star greater than 2.
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product tech and id where
there are more than two
employees okay now you can also use a
where clause along with the having
clause in an sql statement
so suppose i want to find the cities
that have more than two employees apart
from houston
so
i can write my query as select
city comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
where
i'll give my condition city
not equal to
houston i'll put it in double quotes
since i don't want to see
the information regarding houston
i'll group it by
city
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if i run this query
you see we have information for
chicago and seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if i want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75 000
i can write it something like this
so select
department
comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
group by
department
and in the having clause
i am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so i will write having
average salary
greater than
75 000.
is another way to use the having clause
let's run this
all right you can see
we have department sales finance and hr
and you can see the employee count where
the average salary
was greater than 75 000
okay
so let me
run you from the beginning what we did
in our demo so first we created a table
called employee then we inserted 20
records to this table
next we explored a few sql commands like
dixtend then we used average
and finally we started with our
group by clause
followed by
looking at how group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost table to find out the profit
then
you learned how to use the having clause
so we explored several different
questions and
learnt how to use
having an sql in this session we will
learn about joins in sql
joins are really important when you have
to deal with data that is present on
multiple tables
i'll help you understand the basics of
joints and make you learn the different
types of joints with hands-on
demonstrations on mysql workbench
so let's get started with what are
joints in sql
sql join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables
sql joins are used to combine rows of
data from two or more tables based on a
common field or column between them now
consider this example where we have two
tables
an orders table and a customers table
now the order table has information
about the order id which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed then
we have the shipped date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped
then we have the product name which
basically is the names of different
products
we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
cancelled
then we have the quantity which means
the number of products that were ordered
and finally we have the price of each
product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order id
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer id which is
the primary key for this table
we also have the phone number customer
name and address of the customers
now suppose
you want to find the phone numbers of
customers
who have ordered a laptop
now to solve this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the orders table which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer names who have
ordered a product in the last 30 days
in this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the orders table
okay
now let's discuss the different types of
joins one by one so first we have an
inner join
so the sql inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met
from the diagram a verb you can see that
there are two tables a and b
a is the left table and b is the right
table
the orange portion represents the output
of an inner join
which means an inner join returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here so we
have the select command
and then we give the list of columns
from table a which you can see here is
the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is b
on
a common key column from both the tables
a and b
now let me take you to the mysql
workbench and show you how inner join
works in reality
so here
i'll type
mysql
you can see i have got
mysql workbench
8.0 version installed i'll click on it
it will take some time to
open
okay
i'll click on this local
instance and here i'll give my password
okay
so this is how an sql editor on mysql
workbench looks like
so first of all let me go ahead and
create a new database
so i'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be sql underscore joins
if i give a semicolon and hit ctrl enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if i run it
here you can see i have
sql joins database
created
now i'll use this database so i'll write
use sql underscore joins
okay
now to understand
inner join
consider that there is a college
and in every college you have different
teams for different sports such as
cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables cricket and
football
so i'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricket
next
i am going to
create two columns
in this table the first column is going
to be cricut
id
then
i am going to give
the data type as int and use the auto
increment operator
i am using auto increment because my
cricut id is going to be
my primary key
then i am going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricket team
and for this i'll use
varchar data type and give the length as
30.
i'll give another comma
and
i'll assign my cricut id as primary key
within brackets i'll give
cricket underscore id
cricket id is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have role numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our cricut table
similarly let me just copy this and i'll
paste it here
i'll create
another table called
football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team
and instead of cricket i am going to
give this as football id
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students
i'll change my primary key to football
id
all right
let me run this okay
so now we have also created our
football table
the next step is to insert a few player
names into both the tables
so i'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our cricut
table
so i'll write cricket and
i'll give my
name column
followed by
values and here i'll give some names
such as
let's say stuart
give another comma
the next player i'll choose is let's say
michael
similarly i'll add a few more let's say
we have
johnson
the fourth player i'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
let's say fleming
okay
now i'll give a semicolon and run this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
i'll use
select star from table that is cricket
if i run it you can see i have created a
table and have successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's insert
a few student names
for our football table
so i'll change this to
football
and
obviously there would be students who
will be part of both cricket and
football team
so
i'll keep a few
repeated names let's say stuart
johnson and let's say hidden are
part of both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
langer
and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is astral
i'll just run it
okay you can see there are no errors so
we have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
i'll write select star from
football
all right
so we have five players in the football
team as well okay
now the question is
suppose you want to find the students
that are part of both the cricket and
football team in this case you can use
an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select star from
cricket
as i'm using an alias name as c which
stands for cricket
then i am going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as f which is an alias name for the
football table
then i am going to use the on
command or operator
and then i'll give the
common
key that is name here so c dot name is
equal to f dot name
so based on this name column from both
the table my inner join operation will
be performed so let's just run it
there you go so stuart johnson and
hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say i write select c dot
cricut underscore id
comma
c dot
name
comma
f dot
football underscore id
comma
f dot name
from
i'll write
cricket as c
inner join
football as f
on
c dot
name
is equal to f dot name
now if i run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins
so we have a database called classic
models let me
first
use classic models
i'll run this
okay
now let me just show the different
tables that are part of classic tables
all right
so
here you can see there are tables like
customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay
so this product table has information
about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and msrp
let's see what we have in
product lines
if i run it
you see here we have the product line
which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the
textual description for each of the
products this is basically
some sort of an advertisement
all right
now suppose
you want to find the product code the
product name and the text description
for each of the products you can join
the products and product lines table
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we
have product name
and let's say i want the text
description
so i'll write this
column name
okay
then i'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner join
product lines
i can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket i'll give a semicolon
and if i run it there you go so you can
see the different product codes
then we have the different product names
and the textual description for each of
the products
so this we did by joining the products
table and the product lines table
all right
now suppose
you want to find the revenue generated
from each product order and the status
of the product to do this task we need
to join three tables that is orders
order details and products so first let
me show you
what are the columns we have in these
three tables we have obviously seen for
the products table now let me show you
for orders and order details table
so i'll write select star from
orders
if i run it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding
whether the order was shipped or
cancelled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly
let's check what we have under order
details
so i'll write select star from
order details if i run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number
okay
so using the product
orders and order details let's perform
an inner join
so i'll write select
o dot
order number
comma
o dot
status
comma
i need the product name which i'll take
from the products table so i'll write p
dot
product name
now here o
p are all alias name for the tables
orders products and i'll use od for
order details
comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so i'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function
i'll give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
i'll use an alias as revenue
then i'll use my
from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as i'll use an alias name as od
on
i'll write
odot
order number
is equal to
[Music]
od dot
order number
i'll use another inner join
and this time we'll join the products
table so i'll write inner join
products as
p on
p dot
product
code
is equal to
od dot
product code
and finally i'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual all right
okay i think the name of the tables is
actually orders and not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
i mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again
all right there you go so we have the
order number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
now talking about left joins
the sql left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the
left table that is a and only the
matching rows from the right table that
is b so you can see this
overlapped
region
and the syntax
for sql
left join is something like this so you
have the select statement and then you
give the list of columns from table a
which is your left table
then you use the left join
keyword
followed by the next table that is table
b on the common key column so you write
a dot key is equal to b dot key
okay
now in our classic models database we
have two tables customers and orders so
if you want to find the customer name
and their order id you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
i think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table
okay so you can see we have the customer
number
the name of the customer then we have
the contact last name the contact first
name
we have the phone number then there's an
address column there are two address
columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have
our orders table
so i'll write select start from
orders
so i'll write select star from orders
where on this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay
so
let's perform a left join
where we want to find the customer name
and their order ids so i'll write select
c
dot customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number comma
then i want the customer name so i'll
write c dot customer name
then we have the order number column
which is present in the orders table and
let's say i also want to see the status
then i'll give my left table that is
customers
as c
left join
orders
as o
on
c dot
customer number equal to
o dot
customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so b is missing cool
let me run it
all right so here you can see we have
the information regarding the customer
number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if i scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values
this means
for customer number 125 and for this
particular customer name there were no
orders
and similarly if i scroll down you will
find a few more null values you can see
here there are two null values here for
customer number 168 169 there were no
orders available
all right
now to check those customers who haven't
placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
i'll do is here
i'll just continue with this i'll use a
where clause and write where
order
number is null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table
that don't have any orders in their
names
okay
now talking about right joins
so sqlridejoin statement returns all the
rows from the
right table and only matching rows from
the left table so here you can see we
have our left table as a and the right
table as b
so the right join will return all the
rows from the right table and only the
matching rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a
right join table b on the common key
column from both the tables
all right
now to show how ride join works i'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees
so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so i'll write
select star from customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see for
the employees table
here i'll change customers to employees
let's run it okay so we have the
employee number the last name the first
name
we have the extension the email id
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
so based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name
the phone number of the customer
and the email address of the employee
and join both the tables that is
customers and employees
so let me show you
the command so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
comma
then we have c dot
phone i'll give a space here
next
i want
the employee
number from the employee table so i'll
write e dot
employee number
comma
e dot
email from
customers as c
right join
employees
as e
on
e dot
my common key column is employee number
here so i'll write e dot
employee number
is equal to
c dot
we have
sales
representatives
employee number
and i'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see i have
my customer name selected from the
customers table the phone number of the
customer then we have the employee
number and the email address so let me
run it
okay there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go
so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see rights on employees which means
your employees table is to the right
and then we have the customer name and
phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table
so you have a few
employee numbers such as one zero zero
two this one zero five six we don't have
any customer name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is
very widely used in sql known as self
joins so self joins are used to join a
table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email id
and here if you see we have a column
called reports2 now this you can think
of as
the manager column so the way to read is
for example
for employee number
six
the manager is one zero zero two so if
you check for one zero zero two we have
dain murphy
then
if i scroll down
let's see for employee number
1102
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is 1056. so here you can see
who is at 1056 you have mary patterson
similarly if i scroll down let's say
for employee number 1188
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if i check the table at
one one four three we have anthony bow
so
so the employee julie ferrelli reports
to anthony bow
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join
so let me show you how to join this
employees table
i'll write select
and then i'm going to use a function
called concat
within brackets i'll start with my alias
name that is m dot
then i'll write
last name
i'm going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then i'll have my
first name
i'll close this bracket
and then i'm going to give my
alias name let's say manager
comma
next
i'm going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
i'm going to use a separate alias let's
say e which stands for employee so i'll
write e dot
last name comma
and within
single quotes
i'll
give my comma and then i'll write e dot
first name
i close this bracket i'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
i'll write
employees
as
e
inner join
employees
as
m
on
m dot
i'll use my
common key column as employee number so
i'll write
m dot
employee
number
is equal to
e dot
here i am going to use the reports 2
column
and then
i'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay
now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee
so for employee louis bonder
the manager is zerat bonder
similarly if i scroll down
you have there are multiple
employees reporting to this particular
manager similarly we have our manager as
anthony bow and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager and so on
all right now moving
ahead now let's see what a full join is
so sql full outer join statement returns
all the rows when there is a match in
either left or right table now you must
remember that mysql workbench does not
support full outer join by default but
there's a way to do it
so
by default this is how the syntax of
full outer join looks like
now this statement will work on other
sql databases like microsoft sql server
but it won't work on mysql workbench
i'll show you the right way of using
full outer join on mysql workbench
so to sew full outer join i am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally
we'll use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements
so first of all let me write
c dot
customer name so for this example i'm
using the customer table and the order
table
comma
o dot
order number
so i just want to know the customer name
and the
order number related to the customer
from
i have
customers
as
c
left join
i'll write
orders as o
on
c dot
customer number
is equal to
o dot
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this i am going to use my
union operator
so union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next i am going to use my right join
operation
so here instead of left join i'll write
write
restore looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully run
our
full outer join operation you can see we
have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
all right
so that brings us to the end of our demo
session
so let me just run through whatever we
did in this session
so first we created a database called
sql joins
then we created two tables like cricut
and football
then we had
inserted a few
rows to each of these tables then we
used this table to learn about inner
join
next
we used a database called classic models
it had multiple tables so we explored
all of these tables like products there
was product lines orders customers and
employees and learned how to use inner
join left join self join
right join as well as full outer join so
in this video we will learn some queries
in sql we'll also have a look at stored
procedures
and learn about triggers in sql we'll
cover views in sql and look at some of
the important windows functions in sql
now to learn all of these we'll be using
the mysql workbench on windows
so let's get started with sub queries in
sql
so let me head over to my mysql
workbench
so currently i am on my mysql workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so i'll give my password
i'll click on ok
all right so this is my
my sql workbench query editor so first
we are going to learn sub queries let me
give a comment
and write
sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another sql query that is
embedded within the where clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that
i'll be using my
database that is sql underscore intro so
i'll write my command use sql underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
i'll be using the employees table that
is present inside sql underscore intro
let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employees table
so let me first show you
the contents within this table i'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee id employee name age gender
this
date of joint department city and salary
and we have information for
20 employees if i scroll down you can
see there are 20
employees present in our table
so let's say
you want to find the employees whose
salary is greater than the average
salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query
so let me show you how to
write a sub query
i'll write the select statement
in the select statement i'll pass
my column names that i want to display
so the column names i want are the
employee name then i want the department
of the employee and the salary of the
employee
from
my table name that is employees
next
i'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
i'll write salary greater than
after this i am going to write my sub
query
so i will give
select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and i'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once we get the average salary number
will use this
where condition
where salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if i run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is
75 350 dollars now
i want to display all the employees who
have salary greater than seventy five
thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars
so let's run our
sub query
there you go
so there are eight employees in our
table who have
a salary greater than the average salary
of all the employees
alright
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
john's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
john
let me
run the table once again
okay if i scroll down
you see we have an employee
as
john
you see this
our employee id 116 is john and his
salary is
67 000
i want to display all the employees
whose salary is greater than john's
salary so basically all the employees
who are earning more than 65 000 i want
to print them
so let's see how to do it
i'll write
select
i want the employee name
comma
the gender of the employee
i also
want the department and salary
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write where
salary is greater than
i'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket i am
going to give my inner query that is
select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is
john
so within
single quotations i'll give john as my
employee
i'll end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
john has which is sixty seven thousand
dollars now i want the employees who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see 12 rows returned
which means there are 12 employees in
our table who are earning more than 67
000
you see here
all these employees have a salary
greater than 67 000
okay now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a
database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic models i'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website i'll just show you the
website name so this is the website that
is mysql
org
you can see here they have
very nice
articles
blogs from where you can learn
my sequel in detail
so we have
downloaded the database that is classic
models from this website
you see here they have a mysql sample
database if you click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
mysql sample database
and the name of the database is classic
models
all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if i expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have cricket
customers as employees
office there's orders order lines and
many more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table
first let me show you the content that
is present inside
the products table first
if i run this
you see here it says 110 rows returned
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line
we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock by price
msrp
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the
details of all the orders
let me show you
the records
order details tables has
okay so there are thousand records
present in this table you have the order
number the product code
quantity ordered price of each item you
have the order line number as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name
and the msrp of the products whose price
of each product is less than 100
for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables
and we are going to write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here
in the order details table we have a
column called price each
i want to display the product code the
product name and the msrp of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way i'm going to do is i'll write
select
product code comma
product name
now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is products and order
details here you can see this is the
product code column
comma
msrp which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
i'll write
product
code
i'm going to use the in operator
next i'll write my inner query that is
select
product
code
from
my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than
100
let me run
this okay so you can see
there are total 83 products in our table
which have
a price
less than 100 you can see the
price here
okay
now
we learn another advanced concept in sql
which is known as stored procedures
i'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an sql code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
if you want to write a query over and
over again
save it as a stored procedure and then
call it to execute it
so in this example i want to create a
stored procedure
that will return the list of players who
have scored more than six goals in a
tournament
so i have a database called
sql underscore iq
these are a few databases that i have
already created so this database has a
table called players if i expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players
and you can see the columns player id
the name of the player the country to
which the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament
so i'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of
top players who have scored more than
six goals in a tournament
so first of all let me begin by
using my sql underscore iq database
we'll run it
so now we are inside the sql underscore
iq database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are
six players in our table
we have the player id
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so i'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this it should
start with a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter i'll write
amberson amber send
next i'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say i want to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin i'll write my select
statement
i want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from
my table that is
players
where
i'll write goals it's greater than
6
will give a semicolon
then
i'll end my
procedure with a
delimiter
that was double ampersand
next
i'll write
delimiter
and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space
okay
now let's run our
stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our stored procedure
now the way to run a stored procedure is
you need to use the
call method and give the procedure name
that is top underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon
let's execute it
okay there is some problem here
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals and not
goal
let me create that procedure again
okay it says the procedure top
underscore player already exists let's
just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll add it here as well
now let's create it again
okay
now to
call my procedure
i'll write call
space followed by the procedure name
which is top underscore clears
if i run this you can see
we have two players in our table who
have scored more than six goals so we
consider them as the top layers in a
particular tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using
in parameter
all right
so for this example i'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees
based on their
salaries so we have a table
in our sql underscore iq database which
is called employee details
i am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of join city
and salary
using this table i'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write delimiter
this time i'm going to use
forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name let's say
sp for stored procedure
sort
by
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure i'll give my
parameter
in
i'll create a variable var and assign
a data type integer
then i'll write begin
followed by my select statement but i'll
select the name
age
salary
from
my table name that is
emp details or employee details
i am going to order this by
salary
descending
and
i want to
display
limited number of
records so i'm using this
limit keyword and my variable var which
i
created here
i'll end my select statement
i'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and i'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here
all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not
here
you have an option
to see
the stored procedures let me just
refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay
now let's call our stored procedure i'll
write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by
salary
and inside this i'll give my parameter
which was actually var and this var
we have used in
limit
let's say i want to display only the top
three records of the employees
who have the top three highest salaries
okay so let me run it
there you go so amy sarah and jimmy were
the
top three employees who have the highest
salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement
and we called our stored procedure and
passed in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select
statement inside a stored procedure you
can also use other statements let's say
update
so i'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the
in operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be
forward slash
then i'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
i'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable and the type
i'll assign is varchar 20.
i'll again use my in parameter i'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
i'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement i'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and i'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure
if i repress this
you can see i have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all i'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table
okay so we have six rows of information
let's say you want to update the
salary of employee
jimmy or let's say
mary
from 70 000 to
let's say 72 000
or let's say
80 000
so i'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary
and this time i am going to pass in
two parameters the first parameter will
be the
employee name
and next with a comma i'll give my new
salary that i want to
so my
employee name let's say is
mary
and the salary i want
to be updated is let's say eighty
thousand dollars
i'll give a semicolon
and i'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go
if you see this
record
for mary we have successfully updated
the salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learn to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
we will create total employees as an
output parameter and the data type would
be an integer
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total underscore emps using the into
keyword let me show you how to write a
stored procedure using the out parameter
so first i'll declare my delimiter
do forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be sp underscore
count
employees
and inside this i am going to give my
out parameter
and the variable name that is total
underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next i am going to write
begin
followed by
my select statement that is select
i want the
count of total employees
and the output i am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is emp underscore
details
where
sex
is equal to
f which means
female
i'll give a semicolon
next
i'll end it
with the dv limiter and i'm going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what i am doing here
i am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure i am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
emp underscore details so i have used my
out parameter and i am creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer
here in the select statement i am
counting the names of the employees
and the result i am storing it in total
underscore emps
i have
used my where condition where the gender
or the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's
refresh this
okay you can see we have our new stored
procedure sp underscore count employees
now
to call it i'll write call
the name of the procedure that is count
underscore sp underscore count
employees
within brackets i'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
f underscore emp
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll write
select
add the rate
f underscore
emp as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first i'll
call my procedure
and then we'll display the total number
of female employees you can see in our
table we have three female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next topic in this
tutorial on advanced sql now we are
going to learn about triggers in sql
so i'll give a comment here
triggers in sql
so first let's understand what is a
trigger
so a trigger is a special type of stored
procedure that runs automatically when
an event occurs in the database server
there are mainly three types of triggers
in sql we have the data manipulation
trigger we have the data definition
trigger and login triggers
in this example we'll learn how to use a
before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the students roll
number
the age the name and the students marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than 0 our
trigger will automatically set the marks
to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our
table that is
students
all right
so i'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
role number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the
names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or varying character
size i am giving it as 30
finally we have the marks as floating
type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
i'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time i'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is mark
underscore
let's say verify
i'm going to use a before insert trigger
so i'll write before
insert
on my table name that is student
next i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot
marks
is less than zero
then
we'll set
new dot
marks
equal to 50
so this is my
first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0
will assign a value 50 to that student
because
usually the marks are not less than 0 in
any exam
i'll write end if
semicolon and i'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command i'll run it
it says trigger already exists in this
case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
i'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for st
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is mark and
not marks
so here we need to change it as
mark instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created a trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so i'll write insert into student
i'll write
values
i'll give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is let's say ruth
and the marks is let's say 75.00
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student roll number is five zero two
age is twelve
the name is let's say mike
and this time i'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the third
record
for student roll number 503
age is 13
the name is dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by dave is
90
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
504
the age is 10
neem i'll enter as jacobs
and this time again i'm purposely
giving the marks in negative
12 point let's say five
close the bracket
and give a semicolon
and i'll run my insert statement okay so
we have
inserted four rows of information to our
student table
now
let me run
the select query and write select star
from student
if i run this you see the difference
there you go
so
originally we had inserted
for 502
the max was minus
20.5 and for 504
for jacobs the marks was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
marks underscore verify underscore sd
i'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
you give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial concept in sql which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
i'll give a
comment as views in sql
okay
now
to learn views i am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as i mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so i'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so i'll write select
star from customers
okay
i missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name customer number we
have the address state country and other
information
now i'll write a basic view command
using this customer table
the way to write is
i'll write create
view
followed by the view name which is cust
underscore details
then you write as
select
i'm going to select a few
column names from my original customer
table which is this one so i need the
customer name
let's say i need the phone number
and the city so you have this
information here you have the phone
number
and the city
all right
i'll write from my table that is
customers
if i run this
my view that is cust details will be
created
let's run it
there's some error here because the name
of the table is customers and not
customer
i'll give an s and i'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view i can write select star
from followed by the view name that is
cursed underscore details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name
the phone number and the city of the
different customers that we have in our
table
all right
now
let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that i am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table
i am talking about the products table
and the product lines table present
inside classic
models database
so before i start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description
and there's some html description and
image
so
i'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing
create
view
followed by the view name that is
product underscore
description
as
i'll write
select
product
name
comma
then i'll write
quantity
in stock
i also want the msrp
now these three columns
are present inside the products table
and next from the
product lines table i want the text
description
of the products
so i'll write from
products table
i'll give an alias as p
followed by
inner join
my other table that is
product lines as let's say pl
on
the common column that is product line
so p dot
product line
is equal to
i'll give a space
pl dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description
let us run it all right so we have our
view ready
now let me
view
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
view
i like select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock
and textual descriptions of the
different products in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view
instead of product underscore
description you want to give some other
name
so i'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement i'll write rename table
product
underscore description which is my
old name
i want to change this name to let's say
i'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so i'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see i have
renamed my
view
so here if i just refresh it
and i'll expand this you can see we have
the cast details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description view
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
i'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use
show
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
i'll write view
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error
this should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so i'll write drop
view followed by the view name let's say
i want to delete
customer underscore details or cust
underscore details view
i'll write drop view
cust underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cust underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about windows functions
windows functions were incorporated in
mysql in the 8.0 version
so windows function in mysql are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems so using the employees table
present inside my sql underscore intro
database
so we will find the total combined
salary of the employees for each
department
so
first let me switch my database to sql
underscore
intro database
i'll run it ok
i'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we'll partition our table by department
and print the total salary and this we
are going to do using
some windows functions in mysql
so i'll write
select
i want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next i'll write
the sum of salary
over
i want to partition it by
department
so i'll write partition by department
which is dept
and i'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go
so here we have created another column
in our result that is total salary and
for
each of the employees and the respective
departments we have the highest salary
so in finance the highest salary of one
of the employees was 155 000
similarly if i come down we have the
highest salary from hr
if i scroll further we have the highest
salary from it marketing product sales
and
the tech team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its
partition so let me show you how to
use the row number function
i'll write select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so i'll write order by salary
i'll give the
alias as row num
give a comma
and i want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee
from my table that is employees
and i'll order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a row num column and we
have successfully given row numbers to
each of the records you can see it
starts from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first i'll create a table
i'll write create table
let's say i'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's say we have in this table the
student id which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type
barcar
the size is 20.
i'll create
the small table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so i'll write insert
into
demo
values
i'll give one zero one
the name is
shane
give a comma
i'll insert the second student name one
zero two the name is
bradley
we'll give a comma
this time
for 103 we have
two records
let's say the name of the student is
herath
give a comma i'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated 103
next we have 104
the name of the student let's say is
nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student which is kevin we have
two records
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you i'll write select
star from demo
if you see this
we have a few information that are
duplicated in our table
that is for student id 103 and student
id 105.
now i am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table i'll write
select student underscore id comma
student underscore name
i'll give another comma and write
row underscore number
over
within brackets
i'll write partition
by
st underscore id
comma
st underscore name
okay
then i'll write
order by
st underscore id
close the bracket i'll give an alias as
row num
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right now if you see here there is
just one student in the name shane we
have one student in the name bradley
but here if you see for hereth
the second record it says two which
means there are two records for hirad
and if i scroll down there is one record
for nathan and there are two records for
kevin which means kevin is also repeated
ok
now
we are going to see another windows
function that is called rank function
in mysql
so the rank function assigns a rank to a
particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
ranked values when two or more rows have
the same rank
so first of all let me create a table
and the name of the table would be a
random name we'll give it as let's say
demo one and it will have only one
column
let's say variable a of type integer
we'll create this table first
okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table
which is demo one so i'll write
value
one zero one
one zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
i'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
next we have one zero four one zero five
we have one zero six
and
let's say one zero six is also repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo one okay this is done
now
if i write
select
var underscore a
and use my
rank function i'll write rank
over
then i'll
order by
my variable that is var underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo1
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if i run this there you go
so here if you
mark so for variable
a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test rank is two but
for this value which is one zero three
the test rank is repeated because there
was a repetition for one zero three
so we have skipped the rank four here
for one zero four the rank is five now
for one zero five the rank is six now
for one zero six again since the record
was repeated twice
we have skipped the eighth rank and
our rank function has signed the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value one zero seven
the rank is
nine
all right
now moving ahead
we'll see
our final windows function which is
called
first value
so first value is another important
function in
mysql so this function returns the value
of the specified expression with respect
to the
first row in the window frame
all right
so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and i'll write
first underscore
value which is my function and pass in
my employee name
and then i'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
i'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is
employees
so let me run this and see how the
first
underscore value function works
all right so in our table
joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was
115 000
so
the first value function populated the
same
employee name throughout the table you
can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department
so for that you can use the partition
i'll write select emp underscore name
comma
i want the department
and the salary
comma
i'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
i'll write
over
here i'm going to use partition
i'm going to partition it by
department
since i want to know the employee name
who has the highest salary in each
department
and i am going to order by
salary
descending
and i'll give my alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is
employees
so let's
run this and see the difference in the
output
okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for finance jack
had the highest salary from hr it was
marcus
similarly in it was william
if i scroll down for marketing it was
john for product it was alice who had
the highest salary similarly in sales we
had joshua
and in tech we had angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
in this video we'll discuss some of the
frequently asked questions in php
interviews
now the questions are categorized in two
sections beginner and advanced questions
so without any further ado let us get
started with the beginner questions
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development php is also a very
compatible language that is it also
works efficiently with almost 20
different databases such as mysql post
resequal etc
next question what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews
so php is partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name different types of data types in
php
so different data types in php include
integer float
string
boolean
array object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value
while it is print is slower in
comparison to echo because it always
returns a value now as you can see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain good coding
practices which you have to follow while
naming a variable in your php code
so variable name must always begin with
underscore or a letter so it cannot
begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so suppose you want
to name your variable number one two
three so you can use this variable but
you cannot use number at the read one to
three since special characters are not
included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name
now as you can see this is how we
declare a variable dollar my underscore
variable you can also put a number in
between or at the end while naming a
variable just not at the start next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symphony codeigniter cake php and
laravel
moving on how to check if a defined
variable is null or not so is a thank
function is used to check if the defined
variable has any value or not so to use
this suppose you have this block of code
in front of you so
suppose you want to check if this x
variable that you've defined is null or
not so what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return true if it's
not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can
display echo as variable x is not null
while in the case of variable y it is a
null value sin so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code you can use it
use
these special tags
to display
an output directly to the browser now as
you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display and
end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php
also in contrast to the variables there
is no need for a dollar sign before
declaring a constant since the value of
a constant does not change
this is how you can use the define
function to declare a constant suppose
you want to declare the value of pi
as 3.14 throughout your php code and
which cannot be changed so we can use
define for that
next question is related to this
question since
what is constant functioning used for in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you define a function constant
using this defined function and you want
to return this value
you can use this constant function for
that
next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended
next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally
up for each loop so php consists of
total for loops
next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that i'll show you with the help of a
code suppose you want to concatenate or
join these two strings str1 hello guys
and the second string would be and
welcome to simply learn and want to
display these strings together so to do
that you
need to use this dot operator in echo as
you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string then
followed by the dot operator i've given
this space
and then the next order operator because
this is also going to considered as a
string and then the third string
variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question what is the use of
function num ar arguments now this
function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many
values or arguments for past
you can use this function for that so
suppose
in this sample code you want to know how
many
arguments were passed in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument
now we will display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of
this code so in all in all they are
globally accessible so suppose you write
a piece of code and you declare a
variable inside it it would be a local
variable and could be accessed only in
that part of the code
but in case of super global variable
they are accessible throughout the
entire code
they include
global server request posts get files
env cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments
now a single line comment in php can be
made using this hash followed by the
comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and
slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable
also you can use
slash
this is also a
variable so this is a single line
comment now if you try to write
something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment
so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code what you will do is you
will use a slash
star
now write the comment
this is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment
which you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments now let's move on to
the next question that is
name some common applications of php so
some of the
most commonly used php applications are
system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now credit tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that next accessing cookies variables
and set keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews let
us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so
the first question would be how can you
execute a php script from the command
line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed by by opening the command
line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so what is
the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data so as we
discussed earlier
it is a variable that we defined to
store different data types that is
integer float strings etc
while
a double dollar variable is a reference
variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables
now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to simplylearn and we have defined
another variable as well
which contains a string hello now in
this
echo as you can notice what we are doing
is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is
the same string as the name of this
variable so first we are displaying this
variable and then we are referencing
this variable here so what it is doing
is it is referencing the value to
another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method
now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url
sorry web page url while a post method
sends data through http header
in get
the data since the data has been sent
through the url it is displayed in the
url of the webpage so it is not secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of
data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up how to connect to a database
using a php script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview now suppose we have a
php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we're going to do is we will create
another variable con that will be used
to connect it and then we'll use the
mysqli functions which will then
pass these variables to create a
connection so these variable values are
localhost username password these are
the default values now to check if the
connection is connected
what we are going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here
these names can be the name of the
server that you're trying to connect i
have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your php script to
next up
what does final class and final method
mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended while a final
method means that it cannot be
overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function now suppose
this final class is
being inherited by this child class what
the program will return is an error
because once you use this final keyword
this class can not be inherited and
similarly
suppose this function is trying to be
overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now function overloading the same
function is used for different purposes
based on the number of arguments inside
the function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method
now let me show you and demonstrate the
difference with an example
so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title which
does have contain a single parameter and
displays when called upon using this
parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works
next
from this piece of code we can
understand
function overriding suppose you display
a function demo
in a base class and you want to override
this demo function inside the
derived class so what you do is you make
another function with the same name
inside the derived class with some
different properties as you can see it
displays something different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function
you can use the properties of this
function here while if you create
another object that is object 2 for the
derived class and you use this object to
call upon the same demo function you are
overriding this base class demo function
that was inherited instead what it will
use is it will use the properties of the
derived demo function so that is how you
overload or override a class
function in php now let's move on to the
next question that is differentiate
between equal to equal to and triple
equal operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while a triple equals to operator
performs a type save comparison which
means that will that it will only return
true if both operands have the same type
and the same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true
while in this case they both have the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us
next check this equals to equal so since
they both are one and in php it will
display as true since they are equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they are equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error will be issued with an uncaught
exception an exception can be thrown and
caught within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include
now require if a required file is not
found it will throw a fatal error and
stop the code execution while in case of
include if an essential file is not
found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts so
as you can see both of these include and
require i use in the exact same way with
different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it a warning is a critical
error now it is given in condition where
suppose an include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning and final is a fatal error so
it is a critical error resulting in
termination of the code so as we discuss
in the try and catch part of the
question if an exception is thrown and
we do not have a catch function for it
it will display a fatal error which will
return in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference so
ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original
value does not change
so this piece of code here
is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign will call this
function by reference and any changes
made in the variables here will affect
the original ones next question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create
different access points into that block
of code so in a singleton class you can
only create a single object hence
singleton so this piece of code as you
can notice is used to create a singleton
class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then
checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once
next question
how to encrypt a password using php so
php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose you create a
password string and enter your password
as password at the red one two three and
you put it inside the password has hash
function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the this is random it
changes every time you generate the
password since it is encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so
php consists of different sorting
functions which you can use to sort and
give an array automatically so if you
want to sort an array in ascending order
what you need to do is use this sort
function so it will sort this array in
ascending order now if you want to sort
it in descending order
use our sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this so in terms
of value what in terms of value means is
suppose in a given error there are keys
and values so
it will sort the array based on the
values that is this 22 27 and 37 so the
array will be the same since
the values are already sorted now if you
want to sort the array in according to
key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the array
in key that is the first one would be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now if you want to sort
this
array
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php moving on
what will be the output of the following
code now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with 2
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what are construct function and destruct
function in php so a constructor or
construct function is automatically
invoked when a new object of a class is
created and then can be used to
initialize value in class so when you
create a object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked
but you can also use this construct
function to initialize some properties
to give some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript
interactive
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url
next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
arguments does not match the expected
data type the runtime will display an
error and the probe that is a fatal
error and the program will then
terminate now in this code here what we
are doing is we are type hinting so this
is this code is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type
they are expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate so
moving on to our final question of this
video
write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i'm going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute name basket and initialize it
to 0 as the starting position
and then
create a method name score now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by 1. so let's see the solution
now so this is how you create a class
that is basketball
now
inside this class what we are going to
do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we'll be
using construct function as we discussed
to initialize some
default properties for the class so this
construct function is
used to initialize this
basket's
variable to 0. now suppose we do not
call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets the
default value will be displayed as 0
every time now suppose we invoke this
core function every time a basket is
code
this will increase the number of baskets
by one
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question in this video we
will cover 30 important sql questions
that are most frequently asked in the
interviews
now these questions consist of a set of
theoretical and practical questions
so we will use different commands
functions joints and other
functionalities in excel to solve the
problems
so let's get started with the first
question
so the first question is to state the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
now wear and having are very widely used
in sql to solve specific problems
now let's look at the difference one by
one
so where clause is used to filter the
records from the table based on the
specified condition and can be used
without the group by clause on the other
hand having clause is used to filter the
records from groups based on specified
conditions
now where clauses cannot have aggregate
functions so you cannot use sum count
average min and maximum functions in the
where clause
while in the having clause you can
operate on aggregate functions
and those aggregate functions are used
to filter values from a group
now where clause is implemented on rows
or at row level
so for each row of data you have the
where condition applied
now having clauses are implemented on
columns so for each column of data you
have the having condition applied now
another important difference between
wear and having is that the where clause
is executed before the execution of the
group by clause and after the execution
of the from clause
on the other hand the having clause is
executed after groups are created
now we will learn more about wear and
having and understand the usage better
when we tackle practical problems in
this video
now moving to our next question
which is
how is drop different from truncate
so drop and truncate are two different
commands
so drop command is used to drop the
whole table removing the table
definition and its contents while
truncate deletes all the rows from the
table
we can drop the whole table structure in
one go so the view of the table does not
exist
by using the truncate command the
existence of all the rows in the table
is lost but the view in the table exists
now integrity constraints
will be removed in drop command while
the integrity constraints will not be
removed when you use the truncate
command
now moving to our third question now
this is a practical question so we will
be using a
table which is present in my mysql
database so the table name is called
employees and i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
you can see here this is how my
employees table
looks
and
the output query would be something like
this
so here since i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees so i'm using a
min function to find the lowest salary
in the table
and then
i am grouping
all the employees and the results by
department so let's do this on mysql
workbench
okay so here i am on my mysql workbench
first let me go ahead and create a new
sql script so i'll click on this
and that will create a new script
okay so here we'll write our commands
all right so
our question was to
find the
lowest salary
for each department
okay so i've given my comment to make my
commands
and whatever i am doing more readable
so
first before i proceed
i need to
select my database so i am going to use
my sql underscore intro database
so i'll write use sql underscore intro
now this database has a lot of tables
that we'll be using in this
interview questions
video i'll run it
okay
we are in our sql intro database
now there is a table called
employees let me show you the table
first
if i write select star from employees
ok so here you can see this is the table
i am talking about
now these are the
rows
that are present in the table we have 20
rows and here you can see the different
columns we have the employee id employee
name each gender
we have the department city and salary
now this is the same table that we have
also used
in our other videos that are already
live on youtube okay
so
let's solve our question to find the
lowest salary for each department
now
for that
i'll write
select
i'll select my department column which
is dept
comma
and then
to calculate the lowest salary or to
find the lowest salary i'm going to use
the min function so that will return the
minimum salary present in the salary
column
so i'll write min salary as i'm giving
an alias name as let's say
lowest
underscore salary
from
my table name that is employees
then i'll write
group by
department
now i'm grouping it by department
because we want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
now let's run and see the result
there you go
i'll just
move it to the top so that you can see
the results clearly
okay so here we have total seven
departments you can see at the bottom
and
in these seven departments you can see
in sales seventy thousand let's say
dollars was the lowest salary in
marketing we had fifty five thousand
dollars as the lowest salary similarly
if i scroll down we have other
departments like
tech i.t finance and hr so
these are the lowest salary
in each department
all right
now moving to our next question
so our fourth question is
which query will help you fetch unique
values from a column in a table
so this is a multiple choice question
which is another type of question that
is often asked in the sql interviews
now we have multiple queries here and
you need to choose the right query that
will solve our problem
so
since i want to
get the unique values from a column in a
table
so the right option
would be to use the distinct keyword in
the query so if i write select
distinct followed by the column name
let's say you want to find the distinct
cities or the distinct departments in
the employees table so the query would
be select distinct city or let's say
department from the table name that is
employees
hence this is the right option if you
want to find any unique values from a
column
now moving to the
fifth question
now the fifth question says it is
actually a similar question here
we want to write the sql query to fetch
unique departments from the employees
table
so as we saw this is our employees table
and if you want to find the unique
departments from the employees table you
can just write select
distinct
then followed by the column name
which is departments here so dept from
employees
let's
do this
on our mysql workbench
okay so let me just scroll down
and i'll
give a comment here
that is we want to find the unique
departments
so the query would be
select
then i'll use the distinct keyword if i
hit tab it will auto complete
then
i have my column that is department
from
my table name that is employees
if i run this
the query will give us
the unique departments that are present
in the table so here we have total
seven unique departments in the table
you can see here we have sales marketing
product
tech id
finance and hr
but
if you see our original table which is
the employees table
so there are total
20 records
and if you see the department column
there are
multiple departments to which each of
these employees belong to
okay
now moving ahead
now the sixth question is to write an
sql query to fetch the unique values of
departments and print their length
now
this question consists of two parts
first we need to fetch the unique values
of departments that we saw in our fifth
question
and then we want to print the length of
each of the departments so for that i'm
using the distant keyboard to find the
unique departments and then
i'm using the
inbuilt length function that is present
in mysql to find the length of the
department and then i am
using an alias that is length underscore
department from employees so let's say
this on
our workbench
okay
so let me
give a comment
i'll say
unique
departments and length
okay
so the query would be
i'll write
select
distinct
department
and then
let me just scroll down
i'll give a comma
and use my inbuilt length function see
i'm hitting tab to auto complete
and inside the length function i'll give
my column name that is department
i'll give an alias as
department underscore
length
from my table that is
employees this is pretty simple
so first i am finding the unique
departments and then using the length
function i am finding the
length of each department
let's run and see
okay you can see the result here so
sales the length is five
marketing the length of marketing is
nine so basically you are counting the
number of characters that are present in
each of the departments so in sales
there are total five characters in
marketing there are total nine
characters in product there are total
seven characters in it we have just two
letters i and t so hence the
length is two similarly finances
7 and hr is 2 because we have just two
letters h and r
okay so this is another variation of
using distinct along with
any inbuilt function
all right
now moving to the seventh question
the question is what is the use of
dative function in sql
now dative
returns the number of days between two
date or date time or time stamp values
so d diff is another
crucial
inbuilt function
that is present in mysql
so here is how you can use the datedif
function so it will return the number of
days between two dates or date time or
time stamp value so here i have
two date values that is
10th of
april 2021 and i have
30th of
march 2021
so this query will give us the
total number of days that lie between
these two dates and similarly
here is another example of using the
datedif function
so i want to calculate the total number
of days that are present between today's
date so i am using the now function and
between
20th of april 2021
so let's do this demo on the workbench
all right
first i'll give a comment
saying
d d function
okay
now the way to use this
i'll write select
and then
you can see here once i type date
mysql workbench is automatically
suggesting some of the
inbuilt functions i'm going to use
datedif
and within datedif i'm going to pass in
two values so i'm passing in two date
values let's say 2021
april
so i'll write 0 4 and let's say
10th of april
i'll give another comma
and i'll pass in my second date value
that is going to be 30th of
march
2021
all right
now another thing to note here is
the
date value should be present inside
quotations
if you want you can given alias as well
i'll write as
total days
let's run it
there you go it has given us the output
as 10 so there are total 10 days between
31st of march
to
10th of april
now let's see another example
i'll write select
date diff
and we'll pass in
my now function so the now function
returns the
current date that is today's
date
and i'll give another date value let's
say
2021
april 20th
now we'll see the results
if you want you can give an alias name
so that the output is more readable here
i'll run it
okay
so between
today's date and
my previous date that was 20th of
april
there are total 49 days
so today's date is actually
8th of june so between
20th of april and 8th of june there are
total 49 days
all right
now moving ahead
now in the eighth question
we want to write
an sql query to display the departments
that have
more than two employees
so this is our employees table that we
have been using
and here is how the
command looks like so here
we are using both group by and having
now i am grouping by department because
i want to
display the departments that have more
than two employees now for the second
filter i am using the
count function of the employee ids
and checking if the employees
in each department are more than two or
not
let's do this
let me
move down a bit
and i'll give a comment
departments
with more than
two employees
okay
now let's write our query
so i want to select
the department
and then i'm using the count function to
count the
employee ids in each department or the
employees
present in each department
from my table that is employees
i'm going to group by department
and then i'll use having
my count of
employee id
this should be greater than 2.
so
our query will return only those
departments which have more than two
employees
let's run and see
there you go
so we have
total four departments that is sales
product tech and i t
where we have more than
two employees you can see here sales has
four employees product has three
tech has four
and it has three the rest of the
departments like finance hr and others
have less than two employees
now if you want you can give an alias as
well
let's say as
total employees
okay
let me run it again
and here you can see i have the
column name as total employees
okay
so moving ahead
the ninth question we want to display
the details of the employees for all the
departments except marketing
now
here i have my employees table
now if i were to display all the details
of the employees apart from
marketing department
i can give a condition like where
department
not equal to marketing so this is the
way how you write not equal to so you
use the less than and greater than
symbol
another way to do is use the exclamation
mark and give equal to so this means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
now let's do this
i'll move down a bit
and we'll give a
comment as
details of employees apart from
marketing
so the query would be select
star from employees
i'm using star because i want to display
all the details that means i want to
display all the columns
then i am going to use my where
condition where
department
not equal to
marketing
i'll put marketing under
quotes
let's run it and see the results
there you go
so
we have
total
18 rows of information
and if you see the department column we
have all the departments apart from
marketing now if you remember
our employees table had total 20 rows of
information out of which two are missing
which means there were two employees who
were from marketing department and those
departments we are
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving apart
the employees from the marketing
department
all right
now moving ahead
so our 10th question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using
just a where condition to filter our
results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after 31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write
employees
joined
before
april
2010
[Music]
and
after
may 2005.
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
2005
this is one of the formats to use date
values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d value
and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write
2010
march 31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005 and did join less than
31st of
march
2010 this means
employees joined before
2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
okay
now moving ahead to the 11th question
so here we want to find the employee
with the
third highest salary from the table
so i have my employees table here
and my command would look something like
this so here we are going to explore how
to write
sub queries in sql
so
i am using a sub query here where i am
trying to find
the
employees who have the
top three salaries or the top three
employees who have the highest salaries
and from that i am going to filter out
my third highest salary employee so
let's do it on our workbench okay
so i'll come down and let me give a
comment as
third highest salary
okay
so
let me first write down my sql query and
then i'll explain so i'll write select
star from
after that i'll start a bracket and
write my inner query so i'll write
select
star from
employees
order by
salary
descending
then i'll use my limit keyword
and i'll write limit 3
as i'll give an alias name let's say t
and then
i am
again going to use
my order by
salary
limit
one
okay now let me explain you the flow
so first let me run the inner query i'll
select my inner query
and i'll run it
so the inner query returns
my top three employees who have the
highest salary and this is ordered in
descending order since i used salary
descending
now let me just use this okay now you
can see it clearly so these are my top
three employees who have the highest
salary so josef has the
maximum salary followed by
angela and then we have jack now from
this i want to return
only
the record for jack because jack is the
employee
who earns the third highest salary so
for that
i am going to
use the result written by my sub query
or the inner query and on top of this
i am going to order the salary and say
limit equal to 1 so i am again
ordering this salary in ascending order
so what will happen
jack will appear at the top angela will
be at the second place and joseph will
come to the third place and from there
i'm using limit1 so that i can only get
the record for jack
now if i run the entire query you see
the result i have my
employee name as jack who earns the
third highest salary
okay
now moving ahead to the 12th question
the question is to print all the
alternate records in a table
so here is my employees table and from
this table i am going to print all the
alternate records for example i am going
to print my employee id 101 then i am
going to skip 102 and print one zero
three followed by one zero five one zero
seven one zero nine so all the
employee ids that have an odd value
and you can look at this example in
another way of displaying the employees
which have an employee id
of even numbers so 102 104 106 and so on
now the way to do is
either you can use a simple select
clause and say employee id
percentage or modulus 2 equal to 0 which
means i want to filter only those
employees which have an even employee id
else
what you can do is you can use a cte as
you can see here
so cte or the common table expression is
a temporary named result set that you
can reference within a select insert
update or delete statement now it is
used to simplify complex joints and sub
queries and to provide a means to query
hierarchical data
now let's
write this query on our workbench and
see how it works
so before that let me explain you i am
using
a few
new functions such as row number this
will
create a row number for each of the rows
or the records present in my table
and then
from this cte i am going to use my
filter class or the where clause
where rn which is row number percentage
2 equal to equal to 1 so this will
return
only the odd records from the table
let's see how to do it okay
so
i'll give a comment
print
alternate
records
okay
now i'll start with my
simple query which is select star from
employees
where
let's say i want to find only the even
employee ids or the employees who have
an even employee id
so i can use employee id
percentage 2 equal to 0. so it has to be
a perfect division
and the result should be 0 only then i
can get only the
even employees if i run this
okay there was an error here it should
be employees
i'll run it again
you can see here i have printed the
alternate records in a table so we have
skipped 101 because it is not divisible
by two
i've started with one zero two followed
by one zero four one zero six one zero
eight
and then finally we have
one two zero or hundred and twenty
now if you want to print only the
odd records in the table you can use
employee id percentage to equal to one
so you can see here i have one zero one
one zero three one zero five one zero
seven up to
119
now the
best way to do this is
to use a common table expression or cte
so i'll start with
my command that is with cte
as
i'll
start with my bracket i'll write select
star
comma
then i'm going to use my row number
function
so i'll write
row number
then
i'll write over
then i'll use order by
employee id
so this
row number for each of the rows is going
to be created over my employee id column
and that is sorted in
ascending order i will give an alias as
rn which stands for row number
from
my table that is
employees
i'll scroll down
and then i'm going to
close my bracket
i'll write select
let me remove the space here
okay and let's select
star from
cte
where
my
row number
percentage
2 equal to
1.
now
let's
see this from the top
so i have my commentable expression
where
i am
going to create a
row number column named as rn
and this row number column is based on
my employee id column which is sorted in
ascending order
and from that
i am going to filter only those row
number values that are not divisible by
2 or i am going to print only the
odd records from the table so let's run
it and see the results there you go so
here if you mark i have my row number
column created
and i am filtering only the odd records
in the table so it starts with 1 3 5 7
and goes up to 19
and similarly here you can see the
employee ids the name the age gender and
other information
now if you were to print
the even records in the table
the alternate even records you can use
rn percentage 2 equal to 0 let's see the
difference
i'll run this
there you go
so i have my even row number starting
from 2 which goes up to
20
okay so this is how you can print
alternate records in a table
now moving to the next question
now in the 13th question we want to
write an sql query to fetch
all the duplicate rows in a table now
this is another crucial interview
question that is often asked in most of
the interviews
now i have a table
which is named as duplicate table and
here you can see i have some employee id
name and each and a few records are
duplicated for example
101 sam
40 the first record is duplicated and
you can see here
it has the same
values now if you mark
1 0 3
mary and 28 is not duplicated because
here the age is different so this is a
different person
than
compared to the third name that we have
so this is how you can find
the duplicate rules in a table so i am
going to select my employee id name and
age and then count
all the employee ids the names and each
and compare them with whether they are
greater than one or not so if they are
greater than one
then
i'll say that particular record is
duplicated or is present more than one
time in the table
let's
do this
implementation on our workbench
okay
so i'll come down
and let me give my comment as
duplicate records
okay
so
let me first
show you the records that are present in
my table so i'll write select
star from
dup underscore
employees
i'll run it okay you can see here i have
my table that we saw in the slides
so
employee id 101 with name sam and age
40 is duplicated
so we want to find this duplicate record
the way to do is
i'll write
select
e underscore id which is employee id
comma name comma age
comma i'm going to count all of them
so i'll write count star
as
duplicate
count this is my alias name
from
my table that is dup underscore
employees
i'll say
group by
employee id
name
and age
and then i am going to use my having
clause saying having
count of
employee id
is greater than 1
and
count of
name
should also be greater than 1
and
my count of each
should also be
greater than 1.
let's run it and see the results
okay there is some error here
the name of the table should be
employees
okay
let's run again
we have our correct result
that is employee 101 with name sam
and h40 is duplicated so the value is 2.
great
now
moving ahead
now the 14th question is a bit tricky
but in we want to display the employees
with exactly
two
a's in their name
so you see here i have my
employee names and
there are certain employees who have
just
two e's in their names so i want to find
those employees
only
now the way to do is
it is a bit tricky to understand i am
going to break it down and make you
understand
on my mysql workbench
so here you can just have a glance i
write select star from employees where
i am finding the length of my employee
name and then subtracting
my length
wherein i have
replaced my employee name that has a
with a
blank
and if this subtraction is equal to 2
then
that particular employee has two a's in
their names
so let me show this first
let me
first give my comment as
employees
with
two
e's okay
so
first
i'm going to write a select statement
okay before that i'll show you
the records present in my table
okay
if you see here
shane is one of the employees that has
just one e
in its name then we have mary 1 a
dwin has 1a but if you see sarah sarah
has 2a
in the name so we want to extract sara
then jack has
1a again if you see angela angela has 2a
it doesn't matter if it is
uppercase a or lowercase a we just need
to find
if the employees have two e's in their
name
and similarly if i scroll down let me
check if we have
any other employee with two a's in their
name marcus has one david has one sophia
has one
we also have amelia that has two a's
in its name or in her name
and we also have maya
okay
now
let me go ahead and write a sql query
and then i'll explain you what i'm
trying to do
i'll write select
i'm using the length function
and
in the length function
i'm going to replace
then i'll use another function called
upper
on top of employee name
i'll write
a and then replace it with a blank so
i'm using quotations to represent blank
from
employees
okay
let's run this and see the results
you see here
it has given us
the length
of the employee strings after
replacing all the e's with a blank
so here
i'm essentially
converting my employee names to
uppercase
and i'm changing wherever there is an a
i'm replacing
that a with a blank
and then i'm finding the length
so this trick i'm going to use
in my
final query so i'll write select star
from
employees
what i'm going to do is
i'll bring this to the next line i'll
write
length of
employee name
minus
then i'm going to use my
above
condition
i'll
copy this
i'll paste it here
and this value should be
2.
so what i'm doing is i am first
finding out the length of my employee
name
from that
i'm subtracting
the length after replacing
the e is present in the employee name
with a blank and this value should be
equal to 2. the reason being we are only
trying to find the employees who have
two a's in their name
let's run and see the results
okay if you see here
we have sarah angela
emilia and maya who have
two a's in their name so we have
sarah that has 2a angela has 2a amelia
has 2 a's
and then maya also has 2a
okay
now moving ahead
now the 15th question is given a string
how will you extract four characters
starting from the
second position
so i have my string here
which says michael ballack now michael
ballack you must be aware he's a popular
footballer he's from germany and also
was the captain of germany
so from the string michael ballack i am
going to extract four characters
starting from the second position
you can use two inbuilt mysql functions
to
do this the first is called
sub str wherein we pass in the string
then we
give the position from where we want to
extract the characters so here i am
going to extract from the second
position so hence 2
and then the number of characters that
you want to extract which is 4.
the other way is to use the substring
function
which is again similar to the sub str
function
in the substring function also i am
first passing in my input string and
then giving my
starting position which is 2 and then i
want to extract 4 characters from it
let's do it
i'll give a comment
extract
strings
so here i'm going to write select
first i'm going to use sub str
which is my inbuilt function
i'm going to pass in my input string
which says
michael
ballack
and then
i'll give my starting position which is
2 and then the number of characters that
is 4.
let's run it and see the results
you can see here it has given us
i cha so if you see m is at the first
position
from the second position onwards i
needed four characters so m c h and e
these are the four characters starting
from the second position similarly let
me just copy this
and instead of
sub str i am going to use the sub string
function i will write just
ing that becomes sub string
let's
select and run it
and this also returns the same result
suppose you wanted to extract
from the fourth position
you wanted to extract let's say three
characters
let's see the results
it gives us h a and e if you see here
m is the first physician i is at the
second position c is at the third
position
h starts from the fourth position
so h a and e are the next three
characters starting from the fourth
position
so hence this is the result
all right now moving ahead
now my sixteenth question is on how does
self join
work
so self join joins a table to itself
so the table must contain a column x
that acts as the primary key
and a different column let's say y that
stores values that can be matched up
with the values in column x now
this might
not be really easy to understand you'll
get to know once we do this demo so i
have a table
which is called employee manager so this
is my table
now let me tell you how to interpret
this table we have five different
employees starting from employee id one
to employee id five
gary gibbs smith litham and
jimmy are the different employees we
have we have their salaries and now you
have
the employees reporting to which
manager
now if you see here
gary's manager
id is three so if you see a table at 3
we have smith so gary is reporting to 3
or in other words
smith has a employee under him who is
gary similarly
gibbs is reporting to manager id1 or
employee one which is gary so
gibbs manager is gary similarly if you
see for smith smith is reporting to the
person with manager id4 or employee id4
we have latham so litham has one
employee under him who is smith
now litham in our table has no managers
then we have jimmy who's reporting to
the employee id3 who is smith
okay now i want to
use this table and return the name of
the manager for each employee
to do that i am going to use my self
join so here i am
using a self join to join both the
tables
here both the tables mean i'm using
the same table twice so i have written
select e dot employee id e dot employee
name then we have e dot manager id then
i am using another alias for managers so
m dot employee name as
manager underscore name from
employee underscore manager as e
this join means self join employee
underscore manager sm on
e dot manager id equal to e dot employee
id so this is my common column that is
employee id and manager id let's do it
all right
i'll give a comment here
saying self join
and i'll start with myself join i'll
write
select
let me first display my table i'll write
select star from
and my table name is
emp underscore manager
i'll run it
you can see the table here this is the
same table that we saw
in the slides now i'll write my
join query i'll write select e dot
employee id
comma
e
dot
employee name
comma
e dot
manager id
comma then i'm using another alias as m
for
finding the
manager name so m dot employee name as
manager name
there shouldn't be any space in the
alias name then i'll write from
emp underscore
manager as e
join
emp underscore
manager as
m
on
e dot
manager
underscore
id equal to
m dot
emp underscore id
let me run this and we'll see the
results
there you go
so gary
reports to
the manager id 3 so from the table 3
is for smith so gary's manager is smith
gibbs manager is gary
smith's manager is lithum and jimmy's
manager is smith
okay so this is how you can use self
join
now moving ahead with our
next question
so the 17th question
is on which of the following is called a
virtual table in sql so again we have a
multiple choice question
so the answer is
view you can see here
so view is a virtual table that has rows
and columns as they are in a real table
in the database now we can create a view
by selecting fields from one or more
tables present in the database
next moving to the 18th question
so here we want to write an sql query to
fetch the list of employees with the
same salary
again i am going to
use a self join here wherein i'll join
the same employees table
and this is how my
query would look like so i am
selecting distinct employee id so e dot
employee id e dot employee name e dot
salary from employees then i'm joining
employees as e on employees e1 where e
dot salary equal to e1 dot salary
because i want to fetch
the list of employees with the same
salary and i'm ensuring that
the employee ids from both the tables
are different
let's do it
i'll give a
comment here and write
employees
with
same salary
and i'll start with my
query i'll write select
extinct
e dot
employee id
comma
i'll write e dot
employee name comma dot salary
from
employees
as e
then
employs as
e 1
where
e dot salary equal to
e 1 dot
salary
and
e
dot
employee id is not equal to
e1 dot
employee id
i'll give a semicolon and let's print
the results you see here we have
emilia
bela
sheen and sara
who have the
same salary so emilia and sheen have the
same salary of fifty five thousand
dollars bill and sarah have the same
salary of 72 000
okay
now moving to the 19th question
so the question is to write an sql query
to print one row twice
in results from a table so i have a
table here called employees and i want
to print
one row twice in the results
so to solve such kind of problems
you need to use the union all operator
in sql
so union all combines the result sets of
two or more select statements
it does not remove duplicate rows
between the various select statements
all the rows are returned
so let's say i want to print the
employee name and department for those
employees who are from the hr department
now to do this we can use the union all
operator you can see it here so i am
selecting my employee name the
department from my table employs as e
then i am giving my where clause where e
dot department equal to hr
and then i am using the union all
operator
then i am again selecting my employee
name department from employees with
another alias as e1 where e1.department
equal to
hr so let's do this
okay
so i'll give my comment as
print
row
twice
okay
now
i'll start with my query i'll write
select
my employee name
comma the department
from
my table that is employees as e
then i'll use where
e dot department equal to
hr
then i am going to use the union all
operator
so the union all will combine the result
set of two or more select statements
then i am going to write
select emp underscore name
comma
my department
from
employees
as
e1
where
e one dot department
equal to
hr
i'll give a semicolon now let's run it
there you go you can see here
marcus and sophia are from the hr
department and we have printed them
twice in our results
coming to the next question
the question is using the num table
write a query to add 10 when number is 0
20 the number is 1
else
print the number itself
so you can see here i have my table
called num and it has just one column
which is
num id or number id
we have some
numbers here
and
from these numbers i want to add 10 if
the number is 0 20 if the number is 1
else i would print the number itself
so
to answer this question we'll use the
case statement in sql
so the case statement is sql's way of
handling if then logic
the case statement is followed by at
least one pair of when and then
statements
so here you can see i have my case
statement i'm writing one case
my column name and underscore id equal
to 0 then add
plus 10
if it is 1 then add plus 20
else
we'll just return the number id
now let's do this
okay
i'll give a
comment saying using
case statements
okay first of all
let me
display the values present
in my
num table you can see here this is my
table and there are total 12 rows
of numbers
now let's start with our
query i'll write
select
n underscore id
comma
then i'm going to write my case
statement so i'll use the keyword as
case when
n underscore id equal to 0
i'll use then
n underscore id
plus 10
i'll write when
n underscore id equal to 1
then
an underscore id
plus 20
else
i'll just print an id
now i'll end my key statement i'll write
end as
an alias name let's say num underscore
add
from my table that is num
let's run and see the results
okay you can see here
my first
number was 0 so since it was 0 we have
added
num id or n id plus 10 so the result is
10
now
wherever
the num id is 1 for example here we have
added 20 so the
result or the output becomes 21.
similarly here the value was 0 so we
have added 10 the output is 10
and you see here again here we had
another one so we added 1 to
20 so the result becomes 21
and for the rest of the numbers for
example 3
we had 2
the values are the same
okay
now moving ahead
so we have
a table called num1
and using this table
we want to write a query to find the sum
of all positive values and the negative
values
so let's see the table first so this is
my table which is num1 you can see here
we have a list of integers
and
there are positive as well as negative
integers
so for positive values
and the negative values we want to find
the sum separately
so again for this we are using the
case statement you can see here i have
used
two key statements
i'm writing select
and then i'm using the case to find if
the number is greater than 0 which means
it's a positive number so i am
finding out the sum and then i am
checking
case when
the integer is less than 0 so it's a
negative number and i'm finding the sum
for the negative numbers as well
let's do this
okay so
i'll give my comment
as
add
positive and
negative numbers
okay so let's start with our select
query
i'll write select
i'll use the sum function and inside the
sum function
i'll use my case statement so i'll write
case when
num
underscore
integer
okay before that let me just print the
values present in my
table so i'll write select star from
my table name that is num1
okay
so you can see here these are the values
or the list of integers that we have
there are some positive as well as
negative integers
okay let's continue with our query
so here i'm going to write case when
num underscore
integer or int which is my column name
if it is greater than 0
then
i'll return num underscore
int
else i'll say 0
and end my case statement
i'll give an alias as sum of let's say
positive numbers
give a comma
then i'll use another sum function
and inside the sum function we'll use
the case statement to find
the sum of
negative numbers or integers
so i'll write num underscoring if it is
less than 0
then
num underscore end
else
0
and i'll end
ok
and i'll give another alias name as
let's say sum underscore any g which
stands for negative
pos is for positive integers
and then i'll write from my table that
is num1
let's
run it
okay there you go we have our results so
we have two columns
sum of positive integers and sum of
negative integers you can see the
results 19 and minus 14 respectively
okay now moving ahead
now in question number 22 we want to
list the difference between
primary key and foreign key so as you
can see here
primary key is something that can
uniquely identify a record in a table
so if you consider a school database a
primary key would ideally be
the
rule number or the registration number
of the student
because that is unique to all the
students in a school
now
foreign key is the field in the table
that is
primary key to another table
so suppose you have another table called
courses to which the
students of enroll 2
now
if you have a roll number or a
registration number column in the
course table that becomes the foreign
key
now the other difference is primary key
don't accept or cannot accept null
values
while foreign key can accept null values
you can have only one primary key in a
table but you can have more than one
foreign key in a table
now coming to the 23rd question what is
the difference between primary key and
union
so you can have only one primary key in
a table as we discussed in the previous
question
but you can have more than one unique
key in a table a primary key column
cannot have null values but
union can accept null values
now
if you assign a column as a primary key
you create a clustered index
and similarly if you assign a column
with union you create non-cluster index
ok
now coming to the 24th question
what is a check constant in sql
so check constraints are used while
creating tables
check constraint
helps to limit or restrict the values
that can be inserted into a column
for example
we have a
table here let's say dummy1 and
you want to ensure
that every time you insert the
age of
people or persons in the table you want
to make sure that each should be always
greater than zero reason being a person
cannot have or an animal cannot have or
a tree cannot have a negative each
similarly you can set a constant for the
salary column in a table to ensure that
it is always greater than zero because
you cannot earn a negative salary or it
cannot be less than zero
now we are going to create a dummy table
on my mysql workbench and see how
check constraints can be applied
okay
so let's give our comment as
check constraints
all right
so i'm going to create
a table
called
dummy
let's say underscore
sql
now this table
will have
a few columns first we have let's see
eid which stands for employee id
the data type is integer and
i'm going to assign employee id as my
primary key so i'll write
primary key here
okay i'll give a comma
next we'll have a
city column
city column is of type var care or
varying character
i'll give the size as 30
and here
i am going to apply my check constraint
to this
city column
i am going to check
the city
should
take only
values as mumbai
let's see
i'll have my final column that is each
ages of type integer
and here i'm going to check my age
should always be
greater than zero so i'll write check
age
greater than zero
okay
so our dummy sql table has
one primary key constraint and we have
applied two check constraints
on city and h column
let's run this
okay so we have created our table
successfully you can see it here
now
let's insert a few records and we can
see the difference
i'll write insert into
dummy underscore sql
i'll write
values
i'll have my employee ids 101
i am giving
my city as mumbai
which is what you want
and let's see
i'll give my age as
10
now this should perfectly bore because
my city is mumbai and my age
is greater than zero
so
i should be able to insert this record
successfully you can see here
i have inserted
this record to the table
i'll write select star from dummy sql so
that you can check
let's run it
oh there is some mistake i should write
from
okay
let's run it
you can see it here we have one record
or one row returned
now let's see we'll insert another
record
and this time i'm going to give my
employee ideas 102 because it has to be
unique
and this time instead of mumbai i'm
going to give my city as let's say delhi
so i'm not following my check constant
where i am
supposed to give only mumbai i'm
purposely giving
delhi here to see the difference if i
run this
let's see we'll have
ages 40 which is greater than
0
let's run it
you see here we get an error saying
check constraint dummy underscore sql
underscore
check
is violated
similarly
let's see i'll change this to mumbai
again
and instead of 40 let's say i'll give us
minus 30
so your each can never be in negative
numbers
if i run this i get the same error my
check constraint has been violated
because each
should be greater than
zero
okay so this is how you can use check
constraints in sql
now coming to the 25th question
so given two tables a and b
you want to write a query to fetch
values in table b
that are not present in table a
now to answer this question
you can use the left join
so what left join does is
it returns all the rows from the left
table and only matching rows from the
right table
and i've used my
condition as a dot id which is in the
right table should be null
let's write this query on the
workbench
okay
so i'll give my comment
using
left join
first of all let me display my
tables i'll write select star from
e
where on this i have
the ids there are total five ids in
table a similarly
i'll copy this and
we'll see the values that are present in
table b
so again i have five values there are a
few non-matching values as well so i
want to return those non-matching values
that are not present in table a
so for that
i'll write select
id
from
table b
i'll use left join
a
using my id column
this is another way to give the
condition
or you can use the on operator
then i'll give
where
a dot id
is
null
let's run and see the results
there you go so 150 275
are not present in table a but are
present in table b
thank you all for watching this full
course video on php and mysql i hope it
was useful and informative if you have
any query please put them in the comment
section of the video thank you for
watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you